[Musique]
[Rires]
bonjour à tous très heureux de vous
retrouver sur Public Sénat pour suivre
cette neuvième journée de débat sur la
réforme des retraites ici au Sénat les
équipes de Public Sénat continuent à
vous faire vivre ce véritable marathon
parlementaire toute la journée vous
pourrez suivre de nouveau les débats en
direct sur notre antenne et sur notre
site public sénat.fr alors hier le Sénat
adopté l'article 8 du texte qui prévoit
notamment des départs anticipés pour
ceux qui ont commencé à travailler tôt
les sénateurs ont ensuite commencé
l'examen de l'article 9 qui parle des
questions de pénibilité et à ce moment
là et bien les débats se sont
véritablement tendus et pour en parler
on va retrouver quand un calmer dans la
tribune de l'hémicycle du Sénat Quentin
on a encore une soirée électrique au
Sénat oui bonjour Alexandre bonjour à
tous effectivement on est passé à
l'article 9 celui sur la prise en compte
de la pénibilité la droite a voulu
accélérer les débats c'est ça qui s'est
joué en fait en séance hier la droite a
voulu accélérer les débats et faire
tomber c'est à dire supprimer une
myriade d'amendement venu de la gauche
patatras cette gauche c'est laserole a
refusé de se laisser faire écouter
Claude reynaly en séance
je vous signale simplement un seul mot
il y a 70 amendements qui vont tomber ça
aurait fait 70 prise de parole sur le
sujet qui nous intéresse aujourd'hui on
va le remplacer par 70 règles
rappels du règlement c'est intelligent
et cette droite alors cette intelligent
moi j'aimerais plutôt qu'on enlève ça et
qu'on travaille au fond voilà travailler
au fond ça a été assez peu fait hier on
a assez peu parlé pénibilité on a plutôt
vu des échanges très musclés une vive
tension entre la droite et la gauche
avec de multiples de très nombreux
rappellent aux règlements écoutez le
rapporteur René Paul Savary pour lui la
gauche refuse d'avancer contrairement à
ce qu'elle aurait promis initialement en
effet le Sénat devait attendre la
mobilisation du 7 mars pour examiner
l'article 7 et bien la gauche refuserait
de respecter cette Prom esse écoutez-le
oltait le mais
vous et vous avez récolté vous récoltez
ce que vous avez semé la semaine
dernière
vous avez
vous n'avez pas tenu vos engagements et
quand on tient pas les engagements
demandez à vos présidents de groupe ils
savent bien de quoi je parle
demandez-leur ne criez pas comme ça
tenez-vous engagements il était bien
question que l'on puisse débattre du
texte pour aller jusqu'au bout du texte
voilà tenez vos engagements à dire leur
apporteur de la branche vieillesse
peut-être que d'ailleurs et Guillaume
Gontard pourra répondre à votre micro
Alexandre mais finalement un amendement
de la droite et du centre a bien été
adopté en fin de séance vers minuit et
demi mais le débat autour de la
pénibilité ne fait que commencer et on
se doute que les tensions dans
l'hémicycle aussi Alex merci beaucoup
Quentin il faut dire aussi que hier soir
la véritable nouveauté dans ses débats
au Sénat c'est que le gouvernement a
utilisé l'article 44 alinéa 2 de la
Constitution pour rejeter des
amendements des sous amendements
précisément qui ont été déposés par la
gauche sénatoriale qui n'avait pas
encore été examinée par la commission et
donc le gouvernement a demandé qui ne
soit pas examiné donc ça c'est un fait
nouveau dans ces débats tendus au Sénat
justement pour en parler j'accueille sur
ce plateau Guillaume Gontard bonjour
bonjour vous êtes président du groupe
écologiste au Sénat peut-être une
première réaction sur le fait que ça y
est le gouvernement utilise aussi et
bien des outils constitutionnels pour
accélérer les débats au Sénat bah oui
c'est ce qu'on a pu voir pu voir hier
soir
bah je sais pas dans quelles conditions
est le gouvernement et puis la majorité
sénatoriale mais voilà ça volonté c'est
de bloquer le débat quelque part quand
même parce que ce qui s'est passé hier
soir c'est moi je le dis c'est de la
droite sénatoriale avec le gouvernement
bordélise le débat et je pense que c'est
particulièrement grave parce que hier
soir de quoi en parler la pénibilité au
travail on avait un certain nombre
d'amendements de de la gauche des
écologistes sur cette question de
pénibilité et sur les risques chimiques
technologiques sur les charges lourdes
et bien voilà le gouvernement ne
souhaite pas que l'on parle de ça parce
que
il ne souhaite pas que l'on parle de ce
texte parce qu'il n'est pas à l'aise
parce qu'on est dans une imprécision
totale donc on utilise maintenant le 44
de on a fait 47 on a fait l'article 42
l'article 38 je pense qu'on va passer
par tous les tous les chiffres à la fois
de la Constitution et du Règlement du
Sénat pour bâillonner bâillonner le
Sénat Bayonnais le Parlement Bayonnais
le travail parlementaire je pense
franchement que ce n'est pas sérieux ce
n'est vraiment pas sérieux je pense que
nous on est prêt à débattre et on a
toujours été on a des amendements des
amendements de fond alors oui on nous
parle de sous-amendement qui ont été
déposés mais pourquoi on a fait ça
puisqu'on nous retire à chaque fois
l'ensemble de nos amendements pourquoi
on ne peut pas continuer à des conneries
c'est une riposte en quelque sorte quand
vous déposez des sous amendements pour
contrer les amendements le droit
d'amendements c'est un droit
parlementaire strict quand on dépose les
amendements qu'ensuite on nous les
retire avec gérer des artifices on est
bien obligé de un moment donné de
riposter parce que oui on a des choses à
on a des choses à dire donc je pense que
c'est on est vraiment dans une situation
inacceptable et moi franchement je suis
je dis je suis triste de ce qui de ce
qui se passe de l'image que l'on peut
donner on a des gens qui sont dans dans
la rue on a des syndicats uniques qui
attendent une réponse je le rappelle un
courrier a été envoyé au président de la
République où est le président de la
République pour recevoir les syndicats
bah oui bah ils attendent toujours une
réponse jusqu'à quand on va on va être
dans cette situation je pense qu'à un
moment donné il va falloir que le
gouvernement soit saisisse que la
majorité sénatoriale serait saisissent
parce que là ça ne va pas du tout alors
en réponse est bien la droite
sénatoriale estime que les sénateurs de
gauche font je cite de l'obstruction et
hier soir le rapporteur du texte le
sénateur les républicain René Paul
Savary a parlé d'un accord entre les
différents présidents de groupe
politique entre la droite et la gauche
pour qu'il y ait l'examen de ce fameux
article 7 sur les 64 ans après les
manifestations du 7 mars et en échange
les sénateurs de gauche acceptaient et
bien d'accélérer un petit peu les débats
pour aller au bout de cette réforme des
retraites avant Dimanche soir est-ce
qu'il y a eu cet accord et est-ce que
vous ne l'avez pas respecter moi je l'ai
dit très clairement s'il y avait un
accord d'ailleurs ce serait grave pas
d'accord on a un texte on débat d'un
texte avec des articles évidemment qu'on
est arrivé à l'article 7 enfin je veux
dire qui ne pensait qu'on arriverait pas
à l'article 7 vu le nombre d'amendements
parce que encore une fois un peu plus de
3000 amendements déposé au début du
texte par l'ensemble des sénateurs sur
ces 3000 amendements c'est un peu plus
de 1000 par la droite donc on est très
très loin de l'obstruction donc on veut
nous faire croire que ça que c'est de
l'obstruction que c'est de l'obstruction
en fait ce qui se passe tout simplement
c'est qu'ils ne veulent pas débat du
texte un exemple l'amendement de
Monsieur Retailleau pour revenir sur la
clause grand-père qui fait beaucoup
débats et ben en fait sur la suppression
des régimes suppression des régimes du
régime spéciaux ils devaient être
avant-hier soir ensuite hier matin
maintenant on voit qu'il repoussait
qu'il est repoussé parce qu'il n'a pas
de majorité parce que sa majorité se
fissure quand on voit le vote sur
l'article sur l'article 7 justement pour
passer de 62 à 64 ans c'est quand même
intéressant de voir que ça va bien
au-delà de la gauche même dans les rangs
dans marche du groupe RDPI on a deux
personnes qui se sont qui se sont
absolus donc petit à petit oui cette
majorité se fissure petit à petit quand
on avance le texte on s'aperçoit que
c'est un mauvais texte que c'est un coup
dur porté aux françaises et aux Français
et donc ils ne veulent pas aller plus
loin et donc ils font tout pour qu'on ne
puisse pas justement continuer ce débat
parlementaire c'est un vrai aveu de
faiblesse est-ce que vous craignez que
le gouvernement utilise finalement à
l'arme constitutionnelle ultime dans ce
débat au Sénat c'est l'article 44 alinéa
3 de la Constitution qu'on appelle
l'article du vote bloqué en gros si le
gouvernement utilise cet article et bien
les sénateurs devront voter directement
sur cette réforme des retraites avec les
amendements choisis par le gouvernement
vous craignez que l'exécutif l'utilise
évidemment que à un moment donné il
utiliseront certainement je dirais ils
sont ils sont prêts à tout je viens on a
fait tous les chiffres de la
Constitution pour essayer de bloquer le
débat parlementaire donc oui toute façon
que ça soit Emmanuel Macron que ça se
passe gouvernement que ça soit de la
droite scénario il voudrait gouverner
tout seul parce que eux tout seuls ont
raison ah non ça se passe pas comme ça
on est dans une démocratie on est au
Parlement et ben au Parlement on
travaille on propose des amendements on
fait des propositions on construit on
construit un texte il va falloir qu'ils
le comprenne en tout cas nous on sera là
jusqu'à dimanche soir minuit et on va
tenir effectivement le siège Olivier du
socle ministre du Travail dénonce je
cite une mélanchonisation de la gauche
équatoriale comment vous prenez cette
critique
quand on en est là franchement moi j'ai
posé des questions à lui faisait du
socle puisque on n'y comprend rien si
par exemple sur les carrières longues
quelqu'un a compris moi j'aimerais
retourner en Isère et toutes les
questions qu'on me pose de savoir mais à
quel âge on me dit monsieur le sénateur
à quel âge je vais partir à la retraite
tu comprends rien j'ai ça n'a apporté
aucune réponse donc quand on pose des
questions il répond il répond Mélenchon
franchement c'est un peu faible merci
beaucoup à Guillaume bontard d'être venu
ce matin sur le plateau de Public Sénat
avant la reprise de ces débats en séance
dans une minute maintenant sur cette
réforme des retraites justement on va
retrouver Quentin dans l'hémicycle du
Sénat Quentin les sénateurs vont
débattre de l'article 9 de cette réforme
des retraites qui concerne la pénibilité
oui Alexandre un petit mot pour
commencer sur l'ambiance regardez les
sénateurs qui sont en train de
s'installer Olivier du soft qui arrive
juste ici qui vient de saluer la
rapporteur général Franck Riester le
ministre des Relations avec le Parlement
qui est en train de s'installer au banc
des ministres le bord des ministres qui
se trouve juste ici le banc de la
commission qui se trouve juste là alors
effectivement le la pénibilité c'est ce
qui va être au cœur de ces échanges
toute la matinée Alexandre alors hier il
y a déjà eu le
alentours d'une d'un fond qui va comme
cela permettre de travailler à la
prévention des de la pénibilité mais on
va voir maintenant d'autres débats
autour du déplafonnement du compte
professionnel de prévention et on va
voir sur tout Alexandre à la gauche la
gauche qui va essayer de réinstaurer des
critères de pénibilité des critères de
pénibilité qui existaient dans la loi
Touraine et qui ont été supprimés par
Emmanuel Macron en l'occurrence en
l'occurrence ces gouvernements en 2017
Alexandre donc ce sont ces débats sur la
pénibilité que l'on va pouvoir suivre
dans quelques secondes puisque la séance
va pouvoir commencer d'un instant à
l'autre Alexandre effectivement Quentin
on va peut-être dire un mot sur ce qui a
été voté dans la journée d'hier et
d'ailleurs bon tard le président du
groupe écologiste au Sénat en parlait le
Sénat a adopté l'article 8 qui concerne
les départs anticipés à la retraite et
notamment le dispositif carrière long
bien dispositif qui a été qualifié par
beaucoup de sénateurs hier dans le débat
de véritables
usine à gaz et oui et bien ce dispositif
carrière longue il prévoit des départs
anticipés pour les Français qui ont
commencé à travailler tôt avec plusieurs
bornes d'âge différents par exemple ceux
qui ont commencé à travailler avant 16
ans pour en partir à 58 ans ceux qui ont
commencé à travailler entre 16 et 18 ans
pourront partir à 60 ans et ceux qui ont
commencé à travailler entre 18 et 20 ans
pourront partir à 62 ans noter que le
Sénat a voté une modification de ce
dispositif carrière longue qui avait
déjà été annoncé par la première
ministre Elisabeth borne après le vote
du Sénat hier et bien les Français qui
ont commencé à travailler entre 20 et 21
ans pourront partir à 63 ans s'ils ont
bien tout leur trimestres cotisés
évidemment Quentin on va peut-être
toujours sur cette journée d'hier on
peut aussi évoquer et bien ce qui a été
voté par le Sénat pour les maires de
famille tout à fait c'est l'une des
principales avancées qui a été adopté
hier en séance même qu'on peut se
souvenir de ce scrutin Alex qui a eu
lieu vers 16h 17h
280 voix pour y compris sur les bandes
de la gauche c'est cette surcote
effectivement pour les femmes qui ont
tout leur trimestre cotisé et qui
continue à travailler jusqu'à l'âge de
63 et voir maintenant 64 ans et bien
lorsqu'elle continue entre 63 et 64 ans
le Sénat a voté une surcote de leur
pension une forme de bonus jusqu'à 5%
par par année pour cette année
travailler en plus c'était une mesure
voulue par la droite sénatoriale écouter
le chef de fil DLR Bruno Retailleau
premier principe je disais ne pas faire
perdre aux carrière longue leur sens
pourquoi tout simplement parce que une
étude récente l'a montré désormais il y
a au moins la même espérance vie pour
ceux qui en bénéficient par rapport à
ceux qui n'en bénéficient plus on est
plus du tout dans le système que
François Fillon avait inventé justement
pour faire face à un certain nombre de
dispositifs en 2003 voilà c'était
effectivement Bruno Retailleau donc il y
a eu aussi cette surcote donc pour les
les femmes qui ont eu au moins un enfant
alors que au moment où je vous parle et
bien la présidente de séance est en
train de s'installer c'est la Radical
Nathalie Delattre qui est élu en Gironde
qui est en train de prendre place dans
l'hémicycle pour se débat sur la réforme
des retraites qui vont pouvoir commencer
d'un instant à l'autre Alexandre merci
beaucoup Quentin le Sénat qui va donc
aborder l'examen de l'article 9 de cette
réforme des retraites un article
ce qui concerne la pénibilité notamment
ce qu'on appelle le fameux compte
pénibilité avec des mesures qui sont
proposées par le gouvernement notamment
pour lutter contre les maladies
professionnelles pour faire œuvre de
prévention allez on retourne dans
l'hémicycle du Sénat c'est parti pour
cette 9e journée de débat sur la réforme
des retraites 3 dans la discussion des
articles nous sommes parvenus à
l'amendement 33 08 au sein de l'article
9 article 9 je donne la parole à la
présidente madame de roche
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je souhaite
la bienvenue pour une journée que sans
doute sera aussi dynamique que la soirée
que nous avons connu hier et donc madame
la Présidente en application
de l'article 44 alinéa 6 du règlement la
Commission demande sur cet article 9 la
priorité d'examen de vote sur
l'amendement des rapporteurs le 21 38
pour préciser il s'agit du maintien 60
ans de l'âge de la retraite pour
incapacité permanente sujet que nous
avons largement développé en commission
je précise que cette priorité ne fait
tomber aucun amendement
nous reprendrons
s'améliore de jour en jour nous
reprendrons ensuite le cours normal de
nos débats
très bien merci madame la Présidente je
suis donc saisie d'une demande de
priorité de la Commission sur
l'amendement
2138 afin qu'il soit appelé et mis au
voie immédiatement selon l'article 44
alinéa 6 de notre règlement la priorité
est de droit quand elle est demandée par
la Commission saisie au fond sauf
opposition du gouvernement messieurs les
ministres quelle est la vie du
gouvernement sur cette demande de
priorité merci madame la présidente
madame la Présidente de la Commission
Madame et Monsieur les rapporteurs mes
amis messieurs les sénateurs comme
depuis le début de ce débat et
traditionnellement le gouvernement ne
s'oppose pas aux demandes de priorité de
la Commission et s'en remet au Sénat
puisque le gouvernement ne s'y oppose
pas la
priores en train oui oui madame la
Présidente il n'y a pas de souci nous
sommes en train de distribuer je vais
attendre que la distribution soit
finalisée de l'amendement donc 21 38
avant qu'il ne soit présenté
par nos rapports
monsieur le rapporteur j'attends
simplement que là
voilà que l'amendement soit distribué
vous souhaitez simplement que le
rapporteur soit prêt
c'est bon je pense qu'il a été distribué
à tous les sénateurs présents monsieur
le rapporteur pour présentation de cet
amendement merci effectivement nous
sommes très attachés à cette
modification proposée par Elisabeth
Doisneau et moi-même à la commission des
affaires sociales pour faire en sorte
que la capacité
permanente soit dans le cas des
retraites anticipées pris en compte en
restant si possible dans le droit actuel
effectivement elle s'applique des 60 ans
actuellement lorsque vous avez une
incapacité permanente un minimum auteur
de 20% ou si vous êtes entre 10 et 20%
d'incapacité permanente et vous êtes
exposé un certain nombre d'années à
savoir 17 ans pour certains facteurs
d'autres facteurs n'ont pas durées
d'exposition au risque vous pouvez
bénéficier d'une retraite anticipée deux
ans avant l'âge légal donc à partir de
60 ans donc la commission réfléchi à
notre dispositif ou lorsqu'on demande un
effort supplémentaire aux gens
ils risquent effectivement d'être plus
utilisé qu'actuellement et c'est vrai
que il est actuellement insuffisamment
utilisé c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous souhaitons pointer cette
spécificité du doigt vis-à-vis du du
gouvernement ça rentre dans la logique
dans la logique qui nous a animé de
faire en sorte que nous puissions
répondre aux préoccupations de nos
concitoyens ils l'ont largement exprimé
dans la rue et ça c'est me semble-t-il
un élément de réponse tout à fait
déterminant c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous sommes attachés à ce à
cette proposition monsieur le ministre
pour la pour laquelle nous n'avons pas
encore obtenu
satisfaction c'est que nous n'avons pas
été suffisamment
convaincant un argument supplémentaire
mais c'est peut-être une argustine
budgétaire c'est que c'est une mesure
qui relève de la branche ATMP de la
sécurité sociale et non pas de la
branche vieillesse et dans le cas de
l'équilibre de cette réforme il ne la
pénalise pas néanmoins néanmoins c'est
une dépense supplémentaire sur les
comptes publics soyons tout à fait clair
dans ce type de dispositif mais ça nous
paraît être un élément qui peut être
largement partagé sur ses bancs où on a
eu suffisamment peut-être de division
jusqu'à présent où on peut être
peut-être se rassembler sur ce type de
dispositif merci
merci monsieur le rapporteur
puis-je avoir la vie du gouvernement
peut-être un mot d'abord pour dire que
je donne acte bien volontiers à monsieur
le rapporteur que la dépense que
susciterait que créerait une telle
disposition c'est l'été adoptée n'est
pas une dépense qui concerne ce qu'on
appelle les bornes du système de
retraite puisque c'est une dépense qui
serait portée par la branche accident du
travail et maladie professionnelle vous
l'avez dit monsieur le rapporteur ça me
déséquilibre pas le système de retraite
et donc ça ne controvient pas à
l'objectif de retour à l'équilibre du
système de retraite il n'empêche que
c'est une dépense publique c'est une
dépense sociale portée par la branche
ATMP que nous évaluons entre 250 et 260
millions d'euros par an le gouvernement
et c'est une évaluation je précise les
choses brutes pour donner suite à mon
raisonnement le gouvernement a fait un
choix différent de celui que propose
votre commission des affaires sociales
nous avons fait le choix de maintenir
dans cette logique de relèvement des
seuils à 62 ans le départ pour
incapacité permanente mais en
élargissant de manière extrêmement
importante les critères d'accès à cette
retraite anticipée pour incapacité Perm
je ne donne qu'un exemple pour illustrer
le propos actuellement pour bénéficier
d'un départ anticipé au titre de
l'incapacité permanente il faut
justifier d'une exposition à des
facteurs de pénibilité justifiant de la
situation d'incapacité pendant 17 ans
nous avons prévu dans le texte que nous
vous proposons que cette exposition soit
ramenée de 17 à 50 de la même manière
nous avons prévu je l'ai évoqué hier je
crois le fait que ce départ anticipé
puisse être de droit pour les assurer
qui ont un taux d'incapacité reconnu
supérieur ou égal à 20% sans passer par
une seconde procédure médicale
considérons que la reconnaissance d'un
tome égale ou supérieur à 20%, vaut
d'une certaine manière avis médical
permanent si
nous suivons votre commission cela veut
dire que nous supprimons les
assouplissements que nous apportons aux
règles et nous supprimons vous
supprimeriez pardon le passage de 17 à
50 expositions pour rester sur 17 ans
d'exposition mais avec en contrepartie
un départ plutôt c'est pour ça que j'ai
dit il y a un instant que la dépense que
nous estimons entre 250 et 260 millions
d'euros est une dépense brute puisqu'il
faudrait tenir compte aussi de la
moindre dépense supprimée du fait de la
suppression pardon pour se répétitions
des assouplissements que nous proposons
pour toutes ces raisons vous l'avez
compris la vie du gouvernement et
défavorable je dis en ayant bien en tête
que c'est un amendement qui a été adopté
par votre commission mais pour ces deux
principes à la fois le fait que nous
ayons choisi une méthode différente par
assouplissement des critères plutôt que
par bouger de l'âge nous ne pouvons que
nous opposer j'ajoute que nous sommes
dans une logique aussi de lisibilité sur
les soldages à partir desquels on peut
faire valoir le droit à tel ou tel
départ et c'est une raison
supplémentaire pour nous de donner cet
avis défavorable
le rapporteur vous souhaitiez apporter
des précisions
non monsieur le ministre la durée
d'exposition pour certains facteurs de
risque pour d'autres on voit bien qu'il
y a une différence elle peut être prise
par décret donc rien ne vous empêche de
prendre le décret
rien ne vous empêche de prendre le
décret d'Adrien pour faire en sorte que
notre proposition soit élargie
effectivement à cette réduction de la
durée d'exposition quand la commission
pluridique disciplinaire qui serait
effectivement pour ceux qui ont plus de
20 % la capacité qui ne serait pas
réunies il y aura un passage
systématique d'incapacité à 20% sur une
retraite anticipée franchement c'est là
aussi une avancée que vous pouvez faire
quel que soit le vote du Sénat donc je
pense que nos mesures sont
complémentaires et j'inciterai mes
collègues bien sûr elle est soutenir
merci
merci pour explication de votre madame
la Présidente rossignol
merci madame la Présidente bonjour chers
collègues
cet amendement a beaucoup de vertus la
première c'est qu'il protège le droit au
départ en retraite à 60 ans des salariés
en incapacité permanente et la deuxième
c'est qu'il fait tomber aucune aucun
amendement on n'en voudrait que des
comme ça pour autant de remarques quand
même par rapport aux propos du ministre
qui dit que cet amendement va augmenter
les dépenses c'est pas tout à fait vrai
c'est pas une dépense nouvelle c'est une
moindre économie sur votre projet de
réforme des retraites ce qui n'est pas
tout à fait la même chose et c'est un
transfert de charge de l'assurance
vieillesse vers la branche accident du
travail maladie professionnelle donc il
faut être qu'on soit plus précis dans
notre manière de nous exprimer pour pas
faire croire aux gens qui nous regardent
et ils sont quand même très nombreux je
sais pas si vous avez remarqué vous
aussi que nos amendements sont avec des
amendements irresponsables enfin nous
allons en espèces est une du rapporteur
serait des amendements irresponsables
qui ne prendraient pas en compte
le nécessaire équilibre des dépenses
publiques la deuxième chose que que je
voulais dire c'est que en fait c'est
assez diabolique le piège dans lequel
vous essayez de nous mettre monsieur le
ministre c'est le chantage permanent si
vous votez l'amendement ça varie alors
vous supprimerez des mesures importantes
sur les droits d'exposition et ce
chantage là on peut pas l'accepter donc
nous allons voter l'amendement Savary et
nous dénonçons votre chantage
merci Madame Ferré pour explication de
vote
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre effectivement combien de le
préciser ma collègue nous allons voter
cet amendement cet amendement qui va de
dans le bon sens car nous avons dénoncé
depuis le début de ce débat
le reportage qui nous disons sans cesse
ces deux ans de plus pour tout le monde
quel que soit la situation ceux qui
partaient à 62 vont partir à 64 c'est
ceux qui partaient à 60 vont partir à 62
cet amendement propose de maintenir ce
possibilité donc de départ à 60 ans ça
va vraiment dans le bon sens à reconnaît
la pénibilité et la situation parfois
extrêmement difficile pour celles et
ceux qui relèvent de ce dispositif et
non ça n'est pas une dépense nouvelle
puisque on maintient ce qui est organisé
aujourd'hui donc voilà je voulais dire
que notre groupe allait voter
favorablement cet amendement
si chers collègues la parole est donnée
au président carucci
le ministre
franchement après
comment dire le spectacle un peu
désolant ces derniers jours lorsqu'on
rentre sur des amendements un peu
construit
je souhaite vivement que le gouvernement
face à un effort
vous ne pouvez pas considérer que
l'équilibre de votre texte même si vous
avez déjà fait des efforts en début de
débats sur les retraites mais
reconnaissons que
il faut encore des avancées si vous
souhaitez vouloir travailler avec le
Sénat avec l'ensemble du Sénat
il faut accepter des modifications on a
hier malgré le désordre généralisé on a
hier beaucoup insisté sur l'usure sur
les carrières très difficiles sur les
gens qui souffraient en fin de carrière
et qui avaient besoin de partir plus tôt
l'amendement du rapporteur vous permet
de dire que l'allongement que vous
souhaitez de la durée ou le report de
l'âge ne sont pas les mêmes pour tout le
monde et que clairement lorsque
quelqu'un n'est plus en situation de
travailler il faut pas le lui imposer
alors je reconnais bien volontiers que
quand vous prenez des mesures comme
celle là forcément
ça a un coup mais oui bien sûr monsieur
le ministre mais la justice et le fait
de pouvoir présenter aux Français une
réforme en disant elle est difficile
pour tout le monde parce qu'il faut
sauver les comptes publics le compte
public sur l'équilibre des retraites
mais quand même le gouvernement le Sénat
sont attentifs au fait de dire nous
savons qu'il y a des gens pour lesquels
ça n'est pas possible et nous prenons
les mesures nécessaires pour trouver des
solutions n'hésitez pas à Monsieur le
Ministre allez prendre avec nous
madame ponce pour explication de vote
oui merci Madame ma présidente alors
nous aussi nous avions des arguments
construits mais ils ont tous été frappés
par l'article 40 mais là je vois
qu'effectivement vous le contourner donc
par contre comme tous mes collègues je
le soutiendrai
c'est que qu'une des mesures de
transfert de bronches transfert aux
autres branches de des effets de la
réforme là on parle de la TNT mais c'est
pas les seuls et il y a quand même des
transferts invisibilisés sur la maladie
sur la CNAM sur le chômage sur le RSA
sur les minima sociaux tout ça c'est
invisibilisé là comme vous le voulez
mettre cela vous êtes obligé de rendre
visible un des transferts et je pense
qu'ils sont plutôt à hauteur de 5
milliards que de 200 millions alors
monsieur le ministre vous dites bon le
rapporteur vous l'a dit les mesures
d'accompagnement et bien vous allez les
préserver parce que je pense que c'est
le seul souci que vous avez pour rendre
favorable votre avis vous allez les le
faire par décret mais moi je voudrais
revenir sur les 3 milliards
que vous avez mis comme mesure
d'accompagnement sur la capacité
permanente à tort puisque c'était un
maintien donc là nous avons trois
milliards de marge de manœuvre pour
mettre toutes les mesures qu'on voudrait
ajouter 250 à 300 millions là pour le
coup ça tient bien et j'ai jamais eu de
réponse c'est ce qui m'étonne c'est que
la Commission y compris des finances
y compris de la commission sociale
depuis le temps que je dis que il y a 3
milliards de sang qui sont indûment mis
sur les mesures d'accompagnement qui de
fait alors après vous les laisse plus
qu'à 3 milliards personne ce soir penché
sur ça que font ces 3 milliards moi
j'estime en début de cette réunion que
nous avons la démarche de manœuvre pour
3 milliards sans de mesures
d'atténuation de la brutalité de votre
de votre
réforme alors effectivement on peut être
que pour nous l'aurions proposé très
d'ailleurs je l'avais dit
très très naturellement mais nous
n'avons pas
si chers collègues madame Lubin pour
explication de votre
oui monsieur le ministre moi j'ai
monsieur le rapporteur j'ai je reprends
un des arguments que j'avais développé
avant-hier je crois pourquoi ne mettons
pas à profit ce projet de loi puisque
vous cherchez combien de le dire ma
collègue atténuée certains nombres
d'effets
des conséquences qu'il aura pour faire
en sorte que toutes les personnes qui
sont qualifiées de personnes handicapées
puissent avoir un droit de départ à la
retraite à 60 ans certaines restent à 62
en fonction de
soit on est en âge soit on est en
incapacité je ne sais pas très bien je
n'arrive pas à comprendre d'autant que
ces personnes-là ne travaillent pas et
bénéficient d'autres sources de revenus
qui sont prises sur d'autres chapitres
budgétaires de nos comptes de la
sécurité sociale
si chers collègues docteur Chasson pour
explication de vote
merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre monsieur des
ministres de ma présence mes chers
collègues donc moi je suis bien sûr tout
à fait d'accord avec cet amendement
c'est une avancée importante pour les
personnes qui ont travaillé dans un
secteur de pénibilité puisque passer de
d'incapacité de 20% à 10% de d'actions
après maladie professionnelle ou
accident de travail pour voir le
retraite à 60 ans c'est comme une
amélioration très importante pour nos
concitoyens comme une exposition qui
passe de 17 ans à 5 ans donc je pense
que c'est vraiment quelque chose de très
bien pour nous nos concitoyens je pense
qu'il faut le dire
certains disent que il y a beaucoup de
téléspectateurs qui regardent cette CDA
et bien là on peut dire que c'est une
avancée sociale importante et aussi
elle a une réparation des dommages subis
par les assurés exposés à la pénibilité
au cours de leur carrière puisque il y a
un maintien 60 ans de l'âge minimum de
départ de retraite anticipée pour
incapacité permanente donc je pense que
il faut féliciter donc
leur rapporteur et des rapporteurs qui
ont mis en place cet amendement et
j'espère que le gouvernement même pourra
donner satisfaction merci
merci Madame Goulet pour explication de
vote
monsieur le ministre moi je veux très
évidemment cet amendement avec
enthousiasme je remercie d'ailleurs les
rapporteurs au nom de la commission de
l'avoir déposé et je voudrais dire au
ministre qu'il fasse confiance au Sénat
parce que vous voyez que sur tous ces
bancs nous sommes nous sommes d'accord
avec cet amendement et que par ailleurs
l'aspect financier n'a pas été relevé
puisque vous pouvez aussi faire
confiance à la commission des finances
pour stopper l'article 40 quand on en a
besoin donc je pense que c'est un très
bon amendement que c'est un très bon
signal aussi les collègues l'ont dit et
donc nous voterons cet amendement
merci chers collègues monsieur Raynal
pour explication de vote
plus qu'une explication de vote encore
que je le mets dans ce évidemment dans
la dedans c'est une explication du
président de la commission des finances
sur le fait que on nous regarde
maintenant et on travaille sur un
amendement clairement article 40
et comment le président de la commission
des finances peut-il laisser passer un
amendement partie 40 et d'autres ont dit
mais nos amendements sont pas passés
alors je voudrais d'abord remercier le
ministre Attal
parce que si il n'y a pas d'article 40
aujourd'hui sur cet amendement c'est
parce que le ministrehal dans ça DG
a ouvert dans des propos
légèrement ambigus mais permettant
d'ouvrir il a dit qu'il ouvrait qu'il
pensait qu'il y avait un intérêt pour
une discussion sur ce point sans
cependant prendre une position
d'ouverture formelle sur ce sujet je
vous rappelle que pour pouvoir dépasser
l'article 40 il faut qu'il y ait une
intention du gouvernement est-ce que ça
c'était une intention du gouvernement
les juristes pourraient s'en emparer on
va le dire comme ça mais étant interrogé
sur ce point j'ai souhaité aider la
commission pour donner un avis de
recevabilité
alors que
le propos du ministrateur n'engageait
pas formellement le gouvernement et
d'ailleurs on le voit puisque le
gouvernement prend une position
défavorable donc ne couvre pas la
demande donc je remercie vous pouvez
remercier Miss total deuxième point vous
pouvez remercier à ce stade le ministre
au bon parce que il pourrait à tout
moment se lever et dire rareté 40 on
retire il ne le fait pas donc profitons
de ce moment de grâce pour essayer de
voter cette amendement
merci
Président je donne la parole maintenant
à notre collègue monsieur gay
madame la Présidente Monsieur les
ministres mes chers collègues donc c'est
un amendement qui va dans le bon sens
faut le dire par contre que je
qualifierai pas de avancer social ou de
conquête sociale pour des millions de
travailleurs on est loin quand même de
la philosophie d'Ambroise Croizat parce
que je vais revenir sur les chiffres
les départs anticipés pour les accidents
du travail ou les maladies
professionnelles qui entraînent une
incapacité permanente aujourd'hui dans
le texte et vous l'avez reconnu monsieur
le ministre combien de personnes 3000
3000 personnes chaque année et si on est
élargit tous les critères dont je ne
suis pas sûr et c'est pour ça que je
pose la question à monsieur le
rapporteur ça pourrait concerner au
maximum 20 000 personnes voilà de quoi
nous parlons c'est très bien et nous
allons prendre et nous allons le voter
mais lorsque on vient avant-hier de
voter le recul de l'âge légal de 62 à 64
ans pour des millions de travailleurs et
travailleuses et que on a un tout petit
pas pour au maximum 20 000 travailleurs
et travailleuses je mets un bémol sur
grande conquête sociale vous m'en
excuserez et puis après on a une
deuxième chose faut en venir sur les
critères pénibilités qui vont permettre
encore d'élargir il y en a quatre qui
ont été enlevés est-ce qu'on peut se
mettre d'accord d'avoir le débat d'entre
nous exposition aux agents chimiques
dangereux enlever depuis 2017 est-ce
qu'on le rajoute
manutention manuelle de charge est-ce
qu'on continue à l'enlever ou on le
rajoute
posture pénible et vibrations mécanique
c'est les deux derniers est-ce que on
maintient qu'on continue à exclure où on
le rajoute parce que ça ça permet
d'élargir l'assiette vous voyez
peut-être potentiellement de monter à
40000 personnes donc évidemment pour
cela on va le voter mais on fait on est
très loin je vous le dis celui monsieur
le rapporteur d'une grande conquête
sociale ce matin merci chers collègues
madame poumerol
oui merci Madame la présidence
effectivement depuis des jours nous
insistons sur la perte de quatre
critères de pénibilité qui a été décidée
par Monsieur Macron en 2017 et c'est
vrai que je dirais que cet amendement va
certes dans le bon sens mais moi je ne
targnerai je ne taquerai pas d'avancer
social mais plutôt de non recul par
rapport à ce qui était prévu dans le
texte je pense que effectivement il faut
s'entendre sur les critères et comment
ils vont être
inclus de nouveau pour pouvoir élargir
l'assiette parce que combien de le dire
mon collègue Fabien gay cette mesure ne
va toucher que très peu
d'agents et que donc il faut être
vigilant et pouvoir essayer d'élargir au
maximum l'assiette il va toutefois me
salarié dans le bon sens et nous sommes
et nous le voterons donc avec plaisir
pour précision madame la rapporteur
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur les
ministres chers collègues juste une
petite précision budgétaire et je vous
prie de
m'excuser monsieur le président de la
commission des finances en fait juste
une précision cet élément là ne portait
pas à utiliser l'article 40 pourquoi
parce que nous sommes dans finalement
dans ce qui existe dans le périmètre
d'aujourd'hui donc en réalité vous
n'aviez pas opposé les recevabilités par
l'article 40 c'est plutôt pour un sujet
qui qui va suivre c'est la retraite
progressive donc je voulais le préciser
en réalité cette proposition nous
l'avons faite parce que justement nous
pensons que pour un certain nombre de
public les choses sont difficiles le
travail est difficile et que leur
demander cet effort n'était pas
concevable donc je remercie l'ensemble
des collègues qui se sont exprimés pour
dire qu'effectivement eux aussi ils
considéraient que c'était finalement une
mesure de solidarité dans ce projet qui
est difficile on le sait bien passer à
de 62 à 64 ans voilà tout le monde le
dit
ça fait pas l'unanimité c'est clair mais
justement pour ce public en difficulté
nous avons souhaité maintenir et nous
vous invitons à voter cet amendement
alors avant de vous donner la parole
monsieur le ministre
je vous informe que 11 sous amendements
viennent d'être déposés sur l'amendement
numéro 21 38 alors que les explications
de vote avaient déjà commencé monsieur
le ministre je vous donne la parole
merci madame la Présidente simplement de
mots d'abord pour dire au Président
caoutchik si ma fonction me permettait
de donner des avis favorables à tous les
amendements déposés y compris quand je
peux considérer qu'ils ont à l'intérêt
sur le fond alors qu'il contreviennent à
une recherche d'équilibre budgétaire et
quand bien même ça se passe en dehors
des systèmes du bornes des systèmes de
retraite ma vie serait certainement plus
agréable qu'elle ne l'est parfois quand
je suis au bon ceci étant dit je sais
bien que cette amendement présente un
certain nombre d'intérêts et que nous
pouvons en discuter de manière
extrêmement sereine quand on est sur cet
amendement 21 38 de Monsieur Savary
malgré tout je tiens à répéter deux
choses d'abord une première chose que je
répète pas mais que je dis en réponse au
président rénale pour dire que le
gouvernement a lui-même était
circonspect en matière d'articles 40 et
d'appuyer sur la déclaration que vous
avez mentionné la deuxième chose pour
dire que le rapporteur tout à l'heure a
dit à raison que la durée d'exposition
tout comme la question la question
relative à la Commission plurid
partenaires relevé du champ
réglementaire mais le sujet est très
sérieux donc je vais éviter l'expression
fromage ou dessert fromage et dessert
mais ça y ressemble un petit peu et si
par voie réglementaire le gouvernement
m'était en œuvre les assouplissements
auxquels nous avons pensé en plus de
cette adoption le coup n'en serait que
mon chéri il se la fait partie des
choses qui ne sont pas forcément
agréables ceci étant le gouvernement est
à la fois respectueux et soucieux que
soient respectés le vote de la
commission des affaires sociales et
l'expression d'un avis des favorable
n'empêche évidemment pas le Sénat de se
prononcer sur cet amendement et de faire
valoir sa position nous verrons ensuite
dans le cas de la commission mixte
paritaire si les choses prospèrent aussi
elles ne prospère pas le gouvernement
souhaite donc le Sénat puisse se
prononcer sur un certain nombre de
dispositions et j'apprends madame la
Présidente par votre intervention que
des sous amendements ont été déposés sur
cet amendement 21 38
je n'ai pas à dire si le gouvernement
regrette ou pas qu'il a des potes sous
amendement ça serait porté une
appréciation sur leur contenu ce n'est
pas mon rôle par contre le gouvernement
souhaite en que le Sénat puisse se
prononcer sur des sujets de fonds et
celui-ci en étant en application de
l'article 44 à l'unan ne de la
Constitution nous considérons et le
gouvernement considère que totalement ou
sous amendement déposé sur cette
amendement 21 38 et on n'ayant pas été
examinés par la pas été examinée par la
commission
sentir recevable
merci Monsieur le Ministre donc
conformément à l'article 4 alinéa 2 de
la Constitution à l'article 46 bis
alinéa du règlement le gouvernement
s'oppose à l'examen des sous amendements
à l'amendement numéro 21 38 qui n'ont
pas été antérieurement soumis à la
commission madame la Présidente de
commission confirmez-vous que c'est sous
amendement n'en pas été soumis
antérieurement à la commission avant
l'ouverture du débat je le confirme
madame la Présidente merci dans ces
conditions c'est sous amendement ne
peuvent être examinés
je mets donc alors nous avons un rappel
plusieurs rappels aux règlements madame
Rossignol madame Rossignol rappelle au
règlement
donc je vous en prie
nous allons écouter les rappels aux
règlements
non non madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre ça vous a pas suffi hier soir
vous avez aimé ça ou quoi c'est votre
vous avez une petite une petite
addiction d'idente votre rappel au
règlement s'il vous plaît allez-y madame
la Présidente
pendant que vous parlez à ma place je
prendrai la suite monsieur le ministre
une addiction au rappel au règlement 12
amendements là vous déclenchez
ce vote va les recevabilité des
amendements pour 12 amendements mais
autant parfois je peux tout en
contestant et le combattant imaginez en
me mettant votre place pourquoi vous le
faites quand il y en a un grand nombre
mais pour 12 si c'est pas nous priver du
débat sur les sujets sérieux comment et
puis comment ça va finir cette affaire
là si à 12 vous vous énervez dites-le
franchement vous voulez pas débattre
avec nous
comment il s'appelle
[Musique]
au règlement
oui merci madame la Présidente au nom du
44 bis écoutez hier il y a eu des
rappels au règlement du fait des
procédures que vous avez déclenchées
aujourd'hui pour 12 amendements 12
amendements qui étaient extrêmement
important parce que enfin dans cette
émission on allait parler des métiers et
de la vie des gens et de la pénibilité
et puis moi je m'étonne d'une chose
c'est que madame la Présidente de la
Commission se lève en disant que la
commission par exemple appelle en
priorité telle ou tel amendement on sait
pas réunis après on nous dit que comme
ça pas les sous amendements n'ont pas
été examinés par la commission ils sont
rejetés mais réunissez-nous et on va on
va on va on va décider à ensemble
collectivement avec une majorité enfin
c'est extraordinaire de parler au nom de
la commission quand elle ne se réunit
pas la commission c'est la Présidente
c'est le rapporteur c'est qui la
commission
pour rappel au règlement monsieur gay
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je vous
peut pas le faire mais je vais le faire
non mais attendez attendez
pas de provocation on est dans le
règlement
ce matin on a demandé une demande de
priorité et je voulais m'exprimer mais
comme c'est un amendement important je
pensais qu'il fallait le débat comme
nous tout et tout aussi mais à un moment
donné le règlement il est pas fait pour
régler une question politique je vous
l'ai déjà dit mais pour organiser notre
vie commune donc quand on est au banc
ici en bas là moi je l'ai jamais été
mais quand on est au bord
on est rapporteur on est rapporté de la
Commission on entend bien rapporteur de
la commission pas d'un groupe politique
même majoritaire de la commission donc
je lis bien article 44-7 ou tirer 6
pardonnez-moi les demandes de priorité
ou de réserve dont l'effet en cas
d'adoption ou de modifier lors de
discussion des articles d'un texte ou
des amendements comme ça a été fait ce
matin
lorsqu'elle est demandée par la
Commission saisie au fond par la
commission ni par la présidente ni par
le rapporteur par la commission donc moi
je demande une question je vous pose
quand c'est que la Commission a été
c'est réuni pour délibérer sur la
demande de priorité c'est une question
là là c'est l'utilisation du règlement
n'ont pas régler une question politique
mais pour l'organisation de nos débats
parce que si nous crions comme nous le
faisons depuis deux jours beaucoup
beaucoup de nouveautés alors là je vous
le dis ça laissera des traces dans les
prochaines débats dans les prochaines
semaines et les prochains mois voilà non
mais tranquillement et de façon apaisée
donc quand c'est que la Commission a
pris la commission après dans la
Commission comme vous êtes majoritaire
il y a un vote et donc pas de problème
la demande de priorité sera acceptée par
l'ensemble de notre assemblée je vous
remercie
monsieur le rapporteur
les choses avaient bien commencé
[Musique]
mes chers collègues mes chers collègues
on redescend sur terre on se met à la
portée effectivement de nos concitoyens
qui nous demandent des réponses d'accord
très bien ça fait combien de jours que
j'ai passé cet amendement à la
commission combien de jours ça fait
28 Février 28 février depuis le 28
février est-ce que vous ne pensez pas
que quelque part quand on mène une
réflexion approfondie on a quand même le
temps par rapport aux propositions
faites par la Commission de ce retourner
de faire en sorte de faire même des
auditions j'ai refait moins de auditions
par ma part je suis sûr que vous en avez
faire donc vous pouviez effectivement
m'alerter pour que on puisse prenne pour
que l'on puisse prendre les décisions
nécessaires c'est la raison pour
laquelle j'estime mais peut-être ai-je
Tor que les sous amendements qui sont
déposés dans la précipitation sans qu'il
études d'impact ne se relève pas de la
commission me semble-t-il il relève
d'une réflexion que nous aurions pu
ensemble enrichir à travers des réunions
de commission tranquille dans la
sérénité nous mettons éventuellement des
auditions supplémentaires qui auraient
fait que le Sénat aurait pu faire son
travail et rentrer de façon plus
spécifique dans le texte voilà ce
qu'attendent nos concitoyens c'est la
raison pour laquelle il me semble qu'un
amendement comme celui-là qui est
largement partagé largement partagé vous
l'avez dit surtout les bancs méritent
pas franchement d'être à travers ce
texte modifié quelque part vous vous en
seriez rendu compte s'il avait fallu le
modifier avant en conséquence quand tout
le monde sait exprimé il me semble tout
à fait naturel que nous passions au vote
merci
pour Monsieur canard
pour merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Ministre tout d'abord un petit mot
par rapport à rappel au règlement qui a
été porté par Monsieur Olivier nous hier
tardivement dans un état d'acquisition
assez particulier mais je tiens à lui
dire que mon mal-être il est tout à fait
bien surmonté monsieur et nous et que
nos groupes de gauche sont parfaitement
unis c'est pas tout à fait la même chose
chez vous il m'a bien semblé au groupe
huissier je ferme la parenthèse
c'était sur l'article 46 bis madame la
Présidente
mais dans le règlement il y a aussi les
attaques personnelles qui sont évoquées
sur le 46 bis moi j'ai une question à
poser à la droite sénatoriale et à la
droite à l'hygiène
c'est une question c'est combien combien
de sous amendements vous nous permettez
en générosité partagée de déposer sur ce
texte
si vous me dites trois bandes on
déposera 3 5 8
vous avez une autre arme nucléaire
stratégique c'est utiliser le 44 dans
toute sa globalité et d'utiliser donc le
vote bloqué sur la base des rendements
que vous aurez accepté mais si c'est
cela vous voulez pour arrêter le débat
dites le nous le plus vite possible
comme cela les Français seront pris à
témoin de la manière dont vous gérez le
Parlement monsieur Gontard pour rappel
au règlement
merci merci Madame l'ami mais madame
présidente monsieur le ministre
certes il y a le droit mais il y a aussi
l'abus de droit quand on s'écarne
l'esprit de la Constitution la décision
du gouvernement me paraît d'ailleurs
largement improvisée elle augure mal des
discussions à venir sur le débat
parlementaire monsieur le ministre je
vous demande solennellement de prendre
les mesures nécessaires dans la journée
pour que le débat ait lieu il n'est pas
bon de soumettre ainsi le Parlement à un
rapport de force inadmissible recourir à
des instruments de rationalisation du
parlementarisme quand l'on dispose d'une
telle majorité constitue à mes yeux un
aveu de faiblesse de la part du
gouvernement nul besoin de recourir à de
tels artifices il en dispose d'arguments
convaincants
pardonnez la VMA c'est la solennité de
mon propos mais un autre ton ne pouvait
convenir quand le moment est si grave
ce sont les paroles de Philippe Baster
en 2018 sur le texte d'André Chassaigne
pour les retraites agricoles parce que
effectivement le gouvernement utilisé ce
type d'artifice donc je pense que
aujourd'hui on pourrait revenir un petit
peu au sérieux monsieur le ministre ce
n'est pas sérieux d'utiliser et de
supprimer une douzaine de sous
amendements sur un amendement
d'importance comme l'a dit monsieur
karucci a priori plutôt bien construit
et donc quand je continuerons continuons
justement à le construire pour notre
part notre groupe on avait un sous
amendement on est quand même très très
loin de l'obstruction on était pour
ajouter pour discuter pour améliorer
améliorer cette amendement donc je pense
que là franchement on avait
effectivement bien débuté dans les
quelques minutes de notre de notre débat
ce matin je pensais que la nuit avait
été bonne pour chacun je pense qu'il
faut redescendre bah voilà je pense
qu'il faut peut-être revenir de la
sérénité on a il nous reste à peu près
un peu moins de 1000 amendements
travaillons sur ces oui travaillons sur
ces amendements travaillons sur ses
amendements avançons et tout ira bien
merci alors j'ai encore deux rappels au
règlement monsieur le ministre vous
souhaitez prendre la parole avant
merci madame la Présidente quelques mots
d'abord nous nous connaissons depuis
longtemps avec madame la Présidente
rossignols et même si nous avons un
désaccord sur ce texte et peut-être sur
d'autres je pense que madame la
Présidente me demandait
ce qui m'a donné du plaisir hier soir ou
pas
et d'addiction je pense madame la
Présidente que si j'avais utilisé le
même vocabulaire pour vous interpeller
vous m'en auriez fait guérir
donc vraiment vraiment madame la
Présidente je pense que vous me l'auriez
reprocher et peut-être que d'ailleurs
vous auriez eu raison de le faire mais
je ne le fais pas à votre à votre
endroit je le sens simplement je pense
qu'on peut éviter ce genre de
vocabulaire la deuxième chose pour
répondre au président kaner chez le
Président vous avez le droit de déposer
des sous amendements de la même manière
ton application de cet article 44-2 le
gouvernement a le droit de s'opposer à
l'examen de l'ensemble des
sous-amendements déposés sur un
amendement ou un article dès lors qu'ils
n'ont pas été examinés par la commission
préalablement
deuxième troisième point pardonnez-moi
troisième point sur l'intérêt
l'opportunité la pertinence de d'évoquer
d'avoir recours aux 44 de en l'état il y
a deux choses qui m'ont amené à le faire
la première c'est que j'ai en tête un
passage du débat d'hier un débat initié
par le président de compta sur une liste
monsieur le Président de 140 amendements
140 sous amendements que vous aviez
déposé demandant que soit consulté
telle caisse de retraite telle organisme
de conseil 140 amendements
qui avaient été déposé et que vous avez
défendu de manière assez rapide je dois
dire avec une dizaine d'intervenants et
que vous avez tous retiré et donc je me
suis dit j'ai pensé que si nous entrions
dans un débat qui consistait à déposer
des sous-amendements pour les défendre
prendre du temps pour les défendre
retarder le vote et ensuite les retirer
on perdait peut-être en opportunité puis
la deuxième raison c'est que j'ai
regardé rapidement les choses
amendements qui ont été déposés pendant
que les explications de vote avaient
commencé la première remarque que je me
suis faite c'est une remarque identique
à celle de Monsieur le Rapporteur cet
amendement a été adopté par la
commission le 28 février et je considère
que si mes sous amendements qui sont
déposés sont aussi essentielles au débat
peut-être qu'ils auraient pu être
déposés avant le début des explications
de vote ça va vouloir au dernier moment
retarder ce même vote et j'ai regardé
par ailleurs les sous-amands qui ont été
déposés
beaucoup d'entre vous ont une grande
expérience parlementaire et nous savons
tous que lorsqu'on commence à écrire
notamment dans un amendement ou un sous
amendement en général on perd en
lisibilité ou en évidence et la plupart
des amendements en tout cas pour ceux
que j'ai vu commence par notamment et
vise à ajouter à l'amendement du
rapporteur des professions pour dire en
cas d'incapacité permanente notamment
pour par exemple nous avons le sous
amendement
numéro et que je ne dise pas de bêtises
972 qui dit notamment pour les moniteurs
d'écoles de conduite il y a certainement
un travail et une discussion à voir sur
leurs conditions de travail mais je
pense que nous pouvons ainsi décliner
sous amendements autant qu'il y a de
profession deuxième exemple
un amendement insoum amendement numéro
967 qui dit notamment pour les
professeurs des écoles et là celui-ci
m'a encore plus interpellé et en tout
cas à mes yeux il relève d'une volonté
d'obstruction la retraite pour
incapacité permanente ne concerne pas
les agents publics
et on a la des sous amendements qui
viennent sur des professions publiques
qui partent nocturnes sont pas concernés
par le dispositif proposé par le
rapporteur quel est l'autre intérêt que
de retarder le moment du vote et le
retarder Paul Senna la capacité de se
prononcer sur le fond à propos d'un
capacité permanent
pour rappel au règlement
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre mais mes chers collègues la
jurisprudence du Conseil constitutionnel
fait qu'il intervient très très peu sur
l'organisation de nos débats très
rarement monsieur le ministre quand le
gouvernement utilise
l'article 41 et l'article 44 2 de la
Constitution vous vous introduisez
directement dans le débat de notre
assemblée et vous donner par la même la
possibilité aux conseils constitutionnel
de donner un avis sur nos débats en
faisant ça non seulement vous fragilisez
l'article 9 parce que le Conseil
constitutionnel va regarder précisément
dans le détail les modalités de son
adoption et donc va regarder nos débats
mais par ailleurs chers collègues vous
fragilisez aussi la capacité du Sénat à
organiser librement ses débats merci
madame la Présidente
monsieur Reynal pour rappel au règlement
non très très court et sur le même
fondement simplement pour dire que le
rapporteur nous a fait une réponse qui
n'était pas la bonne à m'excusant il a
été questionné sur le fonctionnement de
la commission dont il est le rapporteur
donc moi j'attends toujours qu'il nous
réponde sur le fond sur la question moi
je le dis parce que ce qui me gêne dans
cette affaire qui est le fait que la
Commission soit pas réunie et
préalablement alors que c'est alors que
c'est tout bêtement le règlement c'est
que mes chers collègues c'est votre
c'est vous qui avez ouvert ces questions
réglementaires avec l'article 38 je vous
le rappelle c'est vous qui avez ouvert
le sujet d'un strict respect strict
respect des règles de fonctionnement et
bien si un strict respect que ce respect
est lieu et que les choses se fassent à
l'avenir correctement et donc on a vu
aujourd'hui une façon de faire c'est
fait voilà et à l'avenir faisons les
choses déjà correctement dans l'ordre
c'est tout réglementaire pas plus
merci Madame à la présidente rappelle au
règlement article 44 2
mes chers collègues depuis
presque 10 jours le mot principal c'est
débat vous voulez le débat et vous
regrettez que le débat n'est pas lieu
mais vous voulez une forme particulière
de débat vous voulez le débat sans fin
c'est une stratégie c'est la stratégie
de la paralysie vous avez transformé ces
travées en tranchées c'est votre choix
néanmoins quelle est la mission d'un
parlement ce n'est pas seulement de
parlementer c'est aussi de légiférer
légiférer c'est à dire délibéré voter
décider ce n'est pas votre but
malheureusement
et en choisissant la stratégie de la
paralysie inconsciemment ou
involontairement vous nourrissez vous
renforcer le vent mauvais de
l'antiparlementarisme
vous renforcez
les sirènes du populisme mes chers amis
attention au boomerang
[Applaudissements]
on avait bien démarré
on se met à peu près d'accord sur un
amendement et au moment des explications
de vote 19 sous amendements
sincèrement si ça c'est pas de
l'obstruction je sais pas comment ça
s'appelle si vous aviez tant d'idées
pour sous-amander cette amendement qui a
été adopté par la commission le 28
février c'était il y a 12 jours pendant
12 jours silence radio et puis d'un coup
une masse d'amendement qui tombe ce qui
veut dire très clairement que votre
intention c'est de ne pas aller au bout
du débat votre intention c'est à chaque
amendement de déposer des sous
amendements c'est de l'obstruction
presque caricaturale à partir de là la
décision du gouvernement d'appliquer le
44.2 est tout à fait normal et légitime
vous l'avez je vous rassure quand vous
étiez au gouvernement largement utilisé
beaucoup utilisé dois-je vous rappeler
que par exemple la réforme Touraine a
été adoptée en deuxième lecture à
l'Assemblée nationale par un vote bloqué
un vote bloqué un vote bloqué par un
détail un vote bloqué donc je pense qu'à
la matière il faut rester assez serein
dire que si on veut aller au bout du
texte il faut que chacun y met du sien
pardon monsieur le Président de canner
j'étais je le reconnais un peu choqué de
votre part parce que je vous estime
beaucoup mais
être en photo entraînement j'ai le
règlement du Sénat pardon de vous dire
ce n'est pas digne de notre assemblée
madame Lubin pour rappel au règlement
non pas Madame Lebara pardon
madame brûlin pardon excusez-moi madame
brûle pour rappel au règlement monsieur
gay je ne vous donnerai pas la parole
une deuxième fois pour rappel au
règlement il y a madame appartient qui
prendra la parole
non non a fait une explication de votre
tout à l'heure c'était pas une deuxième
rappel au règlement madame Brulin pour
rappel au règlement
merci madame la Présidente nous
assistons à une utilisation me
semble-t-il abusive
de la priorité appelée sur certains
amendements qui ne tient plus à assurer
la clarté de nos débats mais qui devient
une arme de destruction massive de
sous-amendement lesquels sous
amendements viennent sous cette forme
parce que un certain nombre de nos
amendements on n'y va pas y revenir mais
c'est important de le rappeler ont été
déclarés y recevables pour des raisons
qui restent tout à fait obscures voilà
pourquoi on en est là aujourd'hui
il n'y a même plus d'arguments
réglementaires sur l'annulation de ces
sous amendements il n'est plus question
que de chiffres tantôt 140 que ça peut
faire tomber et maintenant on en est
arrivé à 12 faire tomber 12 vous ne
ferez croire à personne que vous allez
accélérer le débat en faisant ça parce
qu'à chaque fois que vous utilisez ces
procédures nous le retardons
régulièrement vous le retarder
non
c'est un nom
c'est un nom collectif c'est un nom
c'est un nom c'est un nous collectif
collectivement collectivement par vos
procédures ce débat est retardés enfin
il n'a pas été répondu à la question qui
a posé Fabien gay quand la commission
s'est-elle réunie pour demander cette
priorité va-t-elle le faire et va-t-elle
faire son travail puisque parce que nous
ne pouvons pas admettre que des sous
amendements soit rejetés au motif qu'ils
étaient dans la même veine que des
précédents ou qu'ils n'ont pas été posés
pendant les 12 derniers jours mais vous
savez qu'il s'est passé des choses c'est
12 derniers jours vous savez ce qui se
passe dans le pays depuis cette douze
derniers jours et bien notre débat doit
s'il doit faire collègues
donc oui il y a des choses
pour un rappel au règlement
[Musique]
oui merci même ma présidente alors je
veux rappeler effectivement que nous
défendons cet amendement seulement moi
j'ai pas encore perçu pourquoi il a été
mis prioritaire il pouvait très bien
être défendu dans sa place donc la
commission effectivement nous a jamais
informé que quel que soit quelque soit
le moment où on reprendra la discussion
à la commission elle aurait pu dire
celui-là on le mettra prioritaire on
vous informe ce qui aurait quand même
permis que ça soit une décision de la
Commission plutôt qu'une décision
simplement du rapporteur
moi monsieur le ministre je suis quand
même étonné vous empêchez donc ces 12
amendements d'être défendus mais vous
les commentez ça c'est quand même
incroyable en malhonnêteté
intellectuelle c'est à dire on a deux
amendements vous dites ils ne seront pas
discutés et vous prenez la parole pour
dire en quoi ils sont ridicules en quoi
ils vous semblent en quoi il vous semble
44 10 on se calme donc je veux dire il y
a vraiment souvent parce que moi je je
comprends pas l'intention de la priorité
de cet amendement et puis là aussi vous
continuellement vous parler de nos
intentions c'est bien vous lisez mais
l'intention en droit je veux dire c'est
très difficile même pour la faute grave
il faut prouver la tension de nuit et je
sais que pour la faute lourde pardon et
que les employeurs ils renoncent parce
que l'intention à la prouvé c'est quand
même très très difficile alors
effectivement vous avez pas voulu
prendre le temps de ces 12 amendements
c'est ce lac disait ma collègue
communiste regardez nous les aurions
défendus le temps qu'on proteste contre
vos méthodes prendra plus de temps que
la défense de nos douze amendements
[Applaudissements]
oui madame la Présidente mon
rappelment s'appuie sur
l'article 13 du chapitre 6 de notre
règlement et les articles suivants
relatifs à l'organisation des travaux
des commissions je suis quand même
extrêmement surpris mes chers collègues
que il n'est pas été répandu ni même
tenté de répondre
dans une approche éloignée à la question
de savoir en quoi la commission des
affaires sociales
pouvaient se préoccuper de la
recevabilité de certains amendements
est-ce une décision solitaire de notre
collègue présidente de commission ou du
rapporteur ou est-ce une décision
collégiale vous voyez j'ai eu le
l'honneur pendant trois ans avant mon
collègue rénal de présider la commission
des finances qui est avec la commission
des affaires sociales celle qui a
examiné qui a à examiner des textes
financiers et qui par ailleurs par
tradition depuis maintenant un certain
nombre d'années et confiait à un élu
depuis un groupe d'opposition et quand
on est dans cette position politique ça
oblige à une certaine modestie
c'est-à-dire qu'il faut quand même très
prudemment observé ce qui relève de
l'espace de décision personnelle du
président par exemple la censure au
titre de l'article 40 des nominations
individuelles que sais-je et ce qui
relève du travail collectif de la
Commission et encore faut-il pour que ce
travail collectif puisse se dérouler
qu'elle se réunissent donc je repose la
question de savoir quand notre
commission des affaires sociales a eu à
examiner la recevabilité d'un certain
nombre d'amendement
lors des
examens de loi de finances nous
réunissons la commission des finances le
matin avant la séance parfois assez tôt
de façon à pouvoir balayer tout un tas
d'examens qui ont été déposés dans la
nuit je ne vois pas en quoi la
commission des affaires sociales ne
pourrait pas faire un travail de même
nature
pour ce Boli pour explication pour
rappel au règlement pardon merci en
vertu donc de l'article 44 bis nous
évoquons ici 12 amendements 12
amendements monsieur le ministre que
vous avez caricaturé parce que vous avez
oublié de dire que dans ces dans ces
sous amendements nous évoquons les
sages-femmes les infirmiers psy les
puéricultrices bon vous voilà hein alors
oui la commission s'est réunie monsieur
Savary et vous l'avez dit
une la fois passée au mois de février
pour dire que votre amendement était
recevable on n'a pas de souci sur ça
mais pourquoi est-il mis en priorité
avec ma collègue Laurence Cohen et
d'autres d'ailleurs nous participons aux
commissions des affaires sociales nous
sommes présentes à la commission des
affaires sociales on peut pas dire le
contraire mes collègues vous ne pouvez
pas dire ici sur les bancs qu'avec
Laurence Cohen et mes collègues de
gauche et vous d'ailleurs nous ne soyons
pas attentif à cette commission des
affaires sociales nous y sommes à toute
pratiquement
à toutes non mais ça serait de mauvaise
foi que vous nous disiez ça parce que
nous sommes présentes en commission des
affaires sociales et nous y participons
merci merci de redire madame douanouano
qu'effectivement nous sommes présents
que vous l'avez pas dit merci madame
douanot de reconnaître que nous sommes
présentes à ces commissions des affaires
sociales alors alors
je reviens pourquoi est-ce que le
rapporteur avec la présidente décide de
nous faire passer pour des pantins et de
ne pas réunir à nouveau cette commission
des affaires sociales et pourquoi est-ce
que vous décidez à deux trois ici sur
les bancs de la majorité sénatorial de
ne pas nous réunir
monsieur kerouge pour rappel au
règlement
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre
bis Repetti ta place Sainte nous avons
prévenu et vous recommencez la même
perspective que celle que vous avez
lancée hier soir c'est très très bien
c'est sur la base du 46 2 du règlement
pour que tout le monde soit soit à
l'aise alors plusieurs points puisque
certains nous donnent des cours sur ce
que devrait être le Parlement j'en
profite d'ailleurs pour répondre sans
acrimonie aucune à notre collègue
Hainaut qui nous a interpellé hier
Patrick canard et moi-même pour lui dire
d'une part que c'est très certes
confortable mais on ne choisit pas son
opposition et que effectivement nous
sommes à gauche déterminés contre cette
réforme et ensuite j'ai entendu
également monsieur Pacaud nous faire un
cours sur ce que devrait être le
Parlement alors et je le dis avec
modestie d'ailleurs j'invite à Monsieur
Hainaut à les parcourir s'il le souhaite
j'ai une petite expérience sur la
matière et petite bibliographie qu'il
peut éventuellement consulter sur ce
sujet précisément le Parlement le
Parlement n'est pas
une espèce d'enceinte administrative
dans laquelle il faut prendre
automatiquement des décisions un
parlement c'est aussi la traduction des
rapports de force dans une société c'est
aussi simple que ça et on l'espèce vous
tentez de brider ses rapports de force
alors ne vous étonnez pas ne vous
étonnez pas de la situation que vous
avez vous-même créé je l'ai dit hier je
le répète donc vous livrerez à ce petit
jeu nous ferons exactement le même le
débat n'avance pas c'est un choix
manifestement que vous souhaitez
conforter il est ridicule nous ne
pouvons pas avancer continuons
écoutez monsieur Pacaud vos jugements
n'engagent que vous mais les Français
les Français voient le ridicule de la
situation et on vous remercie
le président Laurent pour un rappel au
règlement
merci madame la Présidente
c'est abus des procédures réglementaires
juste pour rigoler un peu il paraît que
l'imprimerie ici est en rupture de stock
parce que tout le monde apprend par cœur
le Règlement du Sénat voilà où on en est
arrivé mais je voudrais faire un
commentaire sur ce qu'a dit ma collègue
ponce à propos de l'intervention du
ministre
parce que non seulement la commission
nos prend visiblement pas la peine de
réunir la commission des affaires
sociales pour examiner le problème de la
recevabilité des amendements mais
semble-t-il si j'en crois les
commentaires du ministre la liste des
amendements qui sont
déclarésorables et faites sous la dictée
du ministre et ça c'est extrêmement
grave
parce que et pour cette raison je veux
le redire au poids où nous en sommes et
vu l'usage répété de cette
irrecevabilité la réunion de la
commission des affaires sociales après
une suspension de séance devient
absolument indispensable sinon ça veut
dire que cette liste d'amendements
irrosovables seraient dans les couloirs
entre le ministre et la présidence de la
Commission et les rapporteurs c'est à la
Commission d'examiner cette question et
pas au ministre de venir nous commenter
des amendements qui ne seront même pas
soumis au débat
merci
président pour un deuxième rappel aux
règlements monsieur gay mais j'espère
que ça ne sera pas jurisprudence il a il
en a le droit et ensuite je mets au vote
règlement quel article
vient de dire le président Laurent
attendez on vous on vous propose
ensemble
une sortie de crise non mais
je relis je relis parce que vous nous
répondez pas ni le rapporteur ni le
ministre lorsque demandée par la
Commission saisie au fond sur la
question de modifier l'ordre de
discussion d'un article ou des
amendements je dis parce qu'il y a
madame la Présidente prima et donc si je
mens elle le dira lorsque ça nous est
arrivé depuis 5 ans d'avoir des demandes
de priorité soit on l'a évoqué en
commission
soit c'est vrai et président en caoutchi
l'a dit elle a eu
normale elle a prévenu l'ensemble des
chefs de fil par groupe politique pour
dire je demanderai sur tel ou tel
amendement de le placer en priorité vrai
ou pas madame la Présidente vous le
savez on ne l'a jamais découvert en
séance publique ce que vous êtes en
train de faire depuis hier on demandant
des priorités sans réunir la commission
n'est pas acceptable et ce qu'a dit le
président Laurent est extrêmement
important c'est la séparation entre
l'exécutif et le Parlement ce n'est pas
au ministre de décider si tel ou tel
amendement ou sous-amendement est
valable ou pas c'est à la commission qui
fait le tri si la commission se réunit
en 5 minutes et décide ensemble que les
sous amendements ne sont pas recevables
alors nous l'accepterons mais nous ne
pouvons pas tripatouiller le règlement
comme cela nous sommes en train de créer
des précédents extrêmement dangereux
qu'ici demain
c'est un pouvoir autoritaire ou
fascisant il aura toutes les armes parce
qu'ici il n'y a que des républicains
démocrates dans cette mission il aura
tous les pouvoirs pour annuler en
réalité le pouvoir des sénatrices et des
sénateurs et de notre assemblée faisons
attention ne trie pas toujours pas le
règlement comme ça nous arrange
réunissant la Commission en 5 minutes
je mets quoi je mets donc au bois cet
amendement avec un avis défavorable du
gouvernement qui vote pour
je mets au bois l'amendement qui vote
pour
qui vote contre
qui s'abstient
il est adopté monsieur le ministre
merci merci madame la Présidente je
souhaitais madame présente intervenir
mais juste un mot de réaction et le
sénateur game n'en prendra pas ombrage
j'en suis sûr c'est le sénateur vous
dites que je déciderai de ce qui est
recevable ou recevable en réalité pour
être tout à fait précis l'article 44 2
de la Constitution n'autorise pas le
gouvernement à dire si tu en amendement
est recevable il recevable c'est la
prérogative de la commission par contre
l'article 44 2 autorise le gouvernement
à refuser l'examen de sous-amendement et
d'amendements qui n'ont pas été examinés
préalablement par la commission ça n'est
pas une appréciation sur la recevabilité
c'est une procédure constitutionnelle
qui m'autorise aujourd'hui comme membre
du gouvernement a refusé que ce soit
soumis à l'examen des articles qui n'ont
pas fait l'objet d'une adoption
ceci étant ceci étant madame
ceci étant madame la Présidente ceci
étant madame la Présidente je sollicite
de votre bienveillance une suspension de
séance de 15 minutes
je suspends la séance donc pour 15
000 collègues à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
sa suspension s'il vous plaît
et à ce moment là pendant une demi-heure
on parle effectivement de cet amendement
ce dispositif de retraite anticipée pour
incapacité pour les victimes d'une
maladie professionnelle avec un droit de
départ à la retraite à 60 ans jusqu'ici
tout va bien me direz vous mais c'est là
que le gouvernement déclenche l'article
44 2 de la Constitution cet article 44 2
qui lui permet au gouvernement d'écarter
les sous amendements en l'occurrence de
la gauche qui n'ont pas été examinés par
la commission des affaires sociales sauf
que la gauche à ce moment-là prend la
parole avec de multiples rappels aux
règlements vous le voyez lorsqu'il lève
leurs petits livrets verts ça c'est le
règlement du Sénat et cette gauche qui
dénonce le fait que la commission des
affaires sociales n'a pas été réunie et
que des facto ces amendements n'ont pas
pu être défendus parce qu'ils n'ont pas
eu la possibilité de le faire par une
réunion de la commission effectivement
Alex et depuis on voit que ce débats
continuent dans l'hémicycle juste un mot
pour terminer Alexandre
puisque il y a une rumeur qui brise sur
un possible utilisation une possibilité
d'un autre article de la Constitution
dans les minutes voire dans les heures
qui viennent de l'article 44 alinéa 3
sur le vote bloqué Alexandre merci
Quentin et on va en parler avec notre
invité sur ce plateau pendant cette
suspension de séance Roger carotc
bonjour bonjour vous êtes sénateurs les
républicains premier vice-président du
Sénat un mot sur ces nouvelles tensions
ce matin entre la droite sénatoriale et
la gauche sénatoriale on a l'impression
qu'on va avoir du mal à aller au bout de
cette réforme des retraites au Sénat
clairement la gauche ne veut pas de vote
clairement elle le dit d'ailleurs depuis
le début on a eu tout ce qu'il fallait
des centaines de sous amendements
déposés nuits à des rappels au règlement
incessants des explications de vote qui
n'en finissait pas des amendements
identiques déposés à l'infini bon
clairement la gauche ne veut pas voter
je considère que c'est un tort c'est un
tort pas seulement pour la gauche quelle
droite s'exprimer et qui s'exprime
d'ailleurs largement elle a utilisé plus
de 90% du temps de débat depuis 8 jours
mais le Sénat est fait pour voter
l'Assemblée nationale est faite pour
voter on est passé pour discuter à
l'infini du sexe des anges ou être des
groupes de parole nous sommes là pour
faire la loi et nous avons d'ailleurs
voté un certain nombre d'amendements
quand même ces derniers jours qui sont
des apports sur les carrières longues
sur l'emploi des seniors sur
l'invalidité on a fait le boulot mais
maintenant on voit bien que la gauche va
à nouveau bloquer on dit
les sous amendements qui viennent d'être
déposés sur l'amendement priorité
l'amendement était adopté le 28 février
ils sont déposés là à la dernière minute
c'est clairement de dire voilà on va
vous en déposer 12 là l'amendement
suivant vous en déposera 15 et puis 20
et puis 30 bon clairement il y a pas de
votre possible si c'est comme ça je le
regrette infiniment parce que ça veut
dire que le gouvernement qui a déjà mis
en place l'article 44.2 qui permet
d'écarter
les amendements qui n'ont pas été
discutés par la commission risque de
dire si nous voulons un vote il faut
finir par le vote bloqué et ce serait
l'utilisation de l'article 44 3 de la
Constitution je le regrette infiniment
parce que je suis un défense acharné du
Parlement mais quand on bloque
complètement le Parlement de manière
irresponsable et bien il faut attendre
s'attendre à ce qui est des conséquences
franchement la situation hallucinante je
n'ai jamais vu ça en 20 ans le Sénat est
là pour délibérer sereinement pour faire
le travail pour améliorer les textes la
situation de blocage est un sens le
gouvernement qui pourrait utiliser ce
vote bloqué sur cette réforme des
retraites au Sénat rappelez-nous
concrètement qu'est-ce que ça
signifierait si le gouvernement dit al
car enfin article 44 Linéa 3 ça veut
dire qu'il fait voter de manière bloqué
en un seul vote sur les articles en
acceptant seulement les Allemands que le
gouvernement accepte c'est-à-dire pas
les amendements votés par le Sénat mais
seulement les amendements que lui
accepte et quand même une réduction
forte du pouvoir du Parlement mais je
rappelle que pour la loi Touraine
pendant le gouvernement socialiste en
2013 le gouvernement socialiste avait
fait le vote bloqué pour la deuxième
lecture de la réforme Touraine à
l'Assemblée nationale donc effectivement
malheureusement c'est une pratique
possible pour écarter le débat
parlementaire et le fait que la gauche
fasse de l'obstruction conduit à cela
donc selon vous le gouvernement
le choix de maîtriser
que le blocage continue que la gauche
continue ce blocage et il ne peut pas y
avoir de vote dimanche soir soit la
gauche a dit bon allez stop on arrête
tout on fait un vrai débat jusqu'à
dimanche soir et on va au vote et là ça
peut se passer sereinement si ça n'est
pas le cas si le gouvernement veut un
vote et bien naturellement il passera
par le 44 3 ce que dit la gauche
sénatoriale c'est que le droit
d'amendement des sénateurs et un peu
piétiné par la droite territoriale c'est
un droit d'amendement constitutionnel et
que est-ce que ça peut fragiliser et
bien cette réforme de retraite sur la le
moins dictionnaire parce que le Conseil
constitutionnel apprécie en premier lieu
les tentatives de blocage et lorsqu'il y
a blocage lorsqu'il y a effectivement
une tentative d'empêcher le Parlement de
voter le Conseil constitutionnel en
prend vraiment compte et là quand il
verra la masse de rappel au règlement la
masse de la mandement identique les
centaines de sous abondements déposés
une nuit d'Amand le Conseil
constitutionnel dire il y a eu
obstruction et par conséquent les moyens
du règlement ou de la Constitution
devait être mise en place ce que disent
les sénateurs de gauche c'est que c'est
pas normal que la Commission refuse
d'examiner certains amendements qui sont
déposés non mais si vous déposez à tout
moment dans la nuit ou après l'ouverture
de la discussion générale des sous
amendements vous pouvez plus déposer un
amendement des sous-amendements
clairement la Commission peut pas suivre
et donc ça n'est qu'une tentative
d'empêcher le débat donc dans ces
conditions malheureusement je ne sais
pas comment ça va se passer si le
gouvernement n'utilise pas dans d'autres
armes je doute que l'on arrive au vote
sauf si la gauche se ressaisissant
disait nous nous voulons vraiment dans
les trois jours qui viennent débattre
sur un certain nombre d'amendements
forts pour nous auquel cas la discussion
est possible et si c'est pas le cas et
si c'est juste pour faire multiplier des
rappels au règlement des sous
amendements et tout autant dire que le
Sénat ne fait pas son travail René Paul
Savary a parlé hier soir d'un accord
qu'il y avait entre les présidents de
groupe à droite et à gauche pour aller
au bout de cette réforme des retraites
je n'en sais rien moi j'étais pas dans
cette réunion mais clairement on a été
extrêmement
gentleman si je puis dire à l'égard des
groupes de gauche sur ce qu'ils ont
demandé pour le 7 mars sur l'article 7
et tout visiblement ça ne sert pas à
grand-chose la confrontation est
malheureusement devenue la règle au
Sénat ce qui n'était pas l'habitude une
dernière question Roger carotschilt sur
le fond quand même de ce qui a été
discuté ce matin il y avait plutôt un
accord entre les sénateurs de gauche et
les sénateurs de droite pour voter un
amendement sur les travailleurs déclarés
en incapacité permanente et pour qu'il
puisse partir à 60 ans à la retraite
c'est dommage que les débats ait tourné
vinaigre bah oui moi j'ai des fendu je
me suis levé pour défendre cet
amendement et demander au gouvernement
de ne pas s'y opposer parce que ça me
paraît essentiel c'est ça le rôle du
Sénat c'est d'apporter des améliorations
c'est de penser aux gens pas seulement
aux rivalités politiciennes
malheureusement avant même le vote de
cet amendement on a sombré dans les
rivalités merci beaucoup merci à tous
d'être venu sur le plateau de Public
Sénat pendant cette suspension de séance
on va retrouver Quentin calmé en tribune
de l'hémicycle du Sénat Quentin
faites-nous vivre un peu c'est tension
cette matinée de nouveau électrique
c'est juste un mot Alexandre pour vous
dire que la rumeur de l'utilisation dans
le l'article 44 3 de la Constitution se
fait de plus en plus pressante d'après
les sources de Public Sénat
effectivement il y a maintenant et bien
45 minutes on a entendu le gouvernement
utilisé un article de la Constitution
écouter le ministre du Travail
j'apprends madame la Présidente par
votre intervention que des sous
amendements ont été déposés sur cet
amendement 21-38 je n'ai pas à dire si
le gouvernement regrette ou pas qu'il a
des potes sous amendements ça serait
porté une appréciation sur leur contenu
ce n'est pas mon rôle par contre le
gouvernement souhaite en que le Sénat
puisse se prononcer sur des sujets de
fond et celui-ci en étant en application
de l'article 44 à la constitution nous
considérons et le gouvernement considère
que totalement demandé sur cette
amendement 21-38 et n'ayant pas été
examiné par la pas été examinée par la
commission sont irrescevables
on peut le dire et qui a enflammé les
débats ce matin Alexandre pourquoi parce
que la déclenchement de cette procédure
par le gouvernement fait tomber des
facto des sous amendements qui avaient
été déposés par la gauche sénatoriale la
gauche sénatorielle qui est bien dénonce
le fait qu'elle ne puisse pas défendre
ses amendements sur le fond qui se
plaint d'être censuré en quelque sorte
par cette procédure on a vu par exemple
le président du groupe socialiste réagir
écoutez-le nous avons le droit mes chers
collègues de déposer des sous
amendements ça peut être dérangeant pour
vous mais c'est comme ça c'est comme ça
vous avez une autre arme nucléaire
stratégique c'est utiliser le 44 dans
toute sa globalité et d'utiliser donc le
vote bloqué sur la base des rendements
que vous aurez accepté mais si c'est
cela vous voulez pour arrêter le débat
dites le nous plus vite possible comme
cela les Français seront pris à témoin
de la manière dont vous gérez le
Parlement voilà Patrick canin qui évoque
la menace de l'utilisation de l'article
44-3 le vote bloqué qui permet au
gouvernement d'utiliser uniquement les
amendements qu'ils de pardon d'examiner
uniquement les amendements qui le
choisit et bien d'après les informations
dont nous disposons cette se recourt
alors qui 44 3 de la Constitution serait
imminent dans l'hémicycle à la reprise
de 11h05 un dernier mot pour vous dire
que de son côté la droite sénatoriale
assume de voilà vouloir faire tomber
sous un rendement de la gauche écouter
Olivier Pacaud
vous voulez le débat sans fin c'est une
stratégie c'est la stratégie de la
paralysie vous avez transformé ces
travées en tranchées c'est votre choix
néanmoins quelle est la mission d'un
parlement ce n'est pas seulement de
parlementer c'est aussi de légiférer
légiférer c'est à dire délibérer voter
décider ce n'est pas votre but
malheureusement et en choisissant la
stratégie de la paralysie inconsciemment
ou involontairement vous nourrissez vous
renforcer le vent mauvais de
l'antiparlementarisme voilà il est 11h01
Alexandre la séance et programmée pour
reprendre à 11h05 on verra ce qui se
passe à ce moment-là et s'il y a un
déclenchement de l'article 44 alinéa 3
de la Constitution merci beaucoup
Quentin et pour parler de cette matinée
électrique au Sénat accueille sur ce
plateau Laurence Cohen bonjour vous êtes
sénatrice communiste du Val-de-Marne une
réaction à ce qui se passe ce matin le
gouvernement qui utilise un article de
la Constitution pour rejeter des sous
amendements de la gauche qui ont été
déposés un petit peu dans la
précipitation sur un amendement du
rapporteur du texte et ce qu'il y a
quand même une volonté d'obstruction de
la gauche territoriale et de ralentir le
plus possible les débats pour éviter un
vote finale sur cette réforme
c'est que en fait on est empêché de
débattre par la droite qui est parfaite
complexité complicité avec le
gouvernement et avec le ministre Olivier
du soft parce que les sous amendements
que nous avons déposés elle concerne la
vie des gens les conditions de travail
des sages-femmes des infirmiers des
infirmières et on les a déposés ils sont
parfaitement bien ficelés si je puis
dire puisque ils font partie d'un
amendement qui avait été rejeté sous des
prétextes fallacieux déjà donc c'est un
vrai travail que nous avons fait donc un
problème de de la droite du gouvernement
de refuser le débat de fond parce qu'ils
veulent faire passer cette loi qui est
rejetée par la majorité des Français
la première chose est la deuxième chose
quand même je suis membre de la
commission des affaires sociales je suis
Vice-Présidente de la commission des
affaires sociales et aujourd'hui au banc
de la commission il y en a deux qui
décident la présidence et le rapporteur
mais la commission ça n'est pas deux
personnes qu'ils réunissent la
commission des affaires sociales comme
c'est c'est même pas d'usage comme le
règlement le stipule pour qu'on prenne
une décision ils ont la majorité de
toute façon leur déshydrateur sera voté
mais au moins que nous puissions
échanger aujourd'hui là finalement on se
retrouve avec une présidente et un
rapporteur qui ne sont plus la
présidente elle est plus responsable
représentante et oui responsable de la
commission des affaires sociales elle
est responsable d'un groupe politique le
groupe LR le groupe majoritaire donc ça
ne va pas ça sert à quoi d'être membre
de la commission et de travailler
ensemble quand au moment du débat dans
l'hémicycle finalement c'est une ou deux
personnes qui prennent la décision avec
le ministre parce que la suspension la
d'un quart d'heure on les voit ils sont
il y a des conciliabules partout donc il
y a on Bafou enfin on Bafou pas nous
mais en tout cas le groupe majoritaire
et le ministre baful la démocratie dans
cet enceinte et c'est eux qui piétinent
le parlementarisme alors le gouvernement
pourrait je parle bien aux conditionnel
pourraient utiliser aujourd'hui
l'article 44 alinéa 3 de la Constitution
pour bloquer le vote du Sénat sur cette
réforme des retraites c'est-à-dire aller
seulement sur des amendements qui sont
choisis par le gouvernement et puis
voter sur l'ensemble du texte ce serait
un coût très dur porté aux droits du
Parlement écoutez c'est un coup
supplémentaire mais ça commence déjà
depuis avec des priorités qui sont
accordées à un certain nombre
d'amendements donc il y a déjà un tri
des amendements depuis depuis hier donc
là ce serait un une étape franchie
supplémentaire mais je pense qu'en tout
cas ça démontre que ce que je viens de
vous dire et plus que la réalité et
qu'il y a un refus de débat du fond
parce que ils veulent passer en vitesse
et peut-être aussi qu'il y a une peur de
voir une très forte mobilisation encore
demain parce que les gens
majoritairement rejettent cette réforme
et on est nous au niveau de la gauche au
niveau du groupe communiste les
porte-voix de tous ceux et toutes celles
qui rejettent cette réforme parce
qu'elle est mauvaise mais est-ce que
vous reconnaissez quand même l'objectif
de la gauche sénatoriale d'éviter un
vote final sur l'ensemble du texte la
gauche veut absolument parler du fond ce
que refuse la droite et ce que refuse le
gouvernement donc le but c'est
effectivement d'aller au fond des choses
sur chaque amendement quand on est
arrivé avant l'article 7 il nous dit oh
là là il faut absolument arriver très
vite à l'article 7 quand on est arrivé à
l'article qui lui recule l'âge de départ
à la retraite il a fallu bâcler les
choses et puis on continue on est sur la
pénibilité il faut encore aller à toute
vitesse donc finalement le tempo il est
donné par le côté
vraiment autoritaire de la droite et du
gouvernement de faire passer les choses
en force nous on a notre rythme notre
rythme c'est le rythme de la gauche mais
c'est aussi le rythme des gens qui
disent stop à cette réforme est-ce que
dit le gouvernement est aussi la droite
sénatoriale dans ce débat c'est que
quand on lit les dizaines d'amendements
et de sous amendements qui sont déposés
par la gauche et bien en fait vous jouez
sur une déclinaison de métier de
produits chimiques par notamment sur la
pénibilité et s'il n'y a pas justement
un jeu pour rallonger le temps de débat
où est-ce qu'il faut vraiment aller sur
un débat sur sur chaque métier mais
écoutez c'est très important de parler
des métiers parce que ça montre la
pénibilité des métiers et ça fait entrer
la vie des gens dans l'hémicycle parce
que on en parle peu des gens dès qu'on
donne des exemples précis
il y a des huées au niveau des travers
de la droite donc voilà ils sont
obnubilés en disant le Sénat va pas
voter cette réforme bah si on la vote
pas et ben tant pis pour eux et tant
mieux pour pour les gens qui verront que
dans les hémicycles et bien il y a un
certain nombre de parlementaires qui
sont à leur côté et qui sont pour que
cette réforme ne passe pas peut-être un
mot sur le fond une dernière question
Laurence Cohen il y avait un accord ce
matin entre les sénateurs de droite et
les sénateurs de gauche pour permettre
aux travailleurs qui sont déclarés en
incapacité permanente et bien de pouvoir
toujours partir à 60 ans c'est dommage
que le débat est mal tourné finalement
bah oui mais c'est de la faute à qui
c'est de la faute à la droite qui est
fait tout pour crisper les choses s'ils
avaient laissé l'examen de nos 12
amendements on les aurait déjà terminé
depuis longtemps au lieu de ça il serait
10 il ne respecte pas le règlement donc
on fait des rappels au règlement merci
beaucoup
d'avoir réagi assez débats ce matin au
Sénat sur la réforme des retraites donc
réaction sur le plateau de Public Sénat
merci beaucoup on va retrouver Quentin
Calmet en tribune de l'hémicycle du
Sénat Quentin on le disait un des débats
très tendus et une bataille
réglementaire entre la gauche et la
droite qui continue et Alex je vous
ferai un marquer une séance qui ne
reprend pas alors qu'elle était
suspendue pour 15 minutes elle devait
reprendre à 11h05 mais et bien il est
maintenant 11h08 et la séance n'a pas
repris que space que se passe-t-il dans
les coulisses du Palais du Luxembourg il
y a-t-il des tractations en cours ou
effectivement quelque chose qui est en
train de se jouer elle sait ce que l'on
verra à la reprise mais effectivement on
examinait un amendement qui faisait à
peu près consensus on peut le dire sur
un dispositif de retraite anticipée pour
incapacité pour les victimes d'une
maladie professionnelle avec un droit à
la retraite des 60 ans ce dispositif
était en train d'être discuté puis c'est
là que le gouvernement a déclenché
l'article 44 2 de la Constitution cet
article 44 2 qui permet au gouvernement
de demander à suppression le fait qu'on
examine pas des sous amendements qui
n'ont pas été eux-mêmes validé par la
commission écoutez ce qu'on a pensé
Laurence Rossignol c'est-à-dire dans
l'hémicycle
monsieur le ministre ça vous a pas suffi
hier soir vous avez aimé ça ou quoi
c'est votre vous avez une petite une
petite addiction dis donc votre rappel
au règlement s'il vous plaît allez-y
madame la Présidente
pendant que vous parlez à ma place je
prendrai la suite monsieur le ministre
une addiction au rappel au règlement 12
amendements là vous déclenchez
ce vote valeur
voilà Laurence Rossignol qui fait
référence à hier soir à la séance de
hier soir car il y a eu le même
processus l'article 42 44.2 pardon qui a
déjà été utilisé hier soir sur les bancs
de la commission c'est René Paul Savary
qui a répondu à la gauche sénatoriale
écouter le
les choses avaient bien commencé
[Musique]
mes chers collègues mes chers collègues
on redescend sur terre on se met à la
portée effectivement de nos concitoyens
qui nous demandent des réponses j'estime
mais peut-être ai-je Tor que les sous
amendements qui sont déposés dans la
précipitation sentier d'étude d'impact
ne se relève pas de la commission me
semble-t-il voilà on a vu donc des
échanges très musclés et des tensions
vives entre la droite et la gauche
sénatoriale Alexandre merci beaucoup
Quentin effectivement la séance qui ne
reprend pas sur cette réforme des
retraites dans l'hémicycle du Sénat ça
veut dire que les différents
responsables de la commission des
groupes politiques sont en train de
discuter notamment avec le gouvernement
sur la suite de ces débats au Sénat et
la question qui se pose c'est elle
va-t-on vers un blocage du vote et du
débat au Sénat par le gouvernement le
gouvernement en a les moyens avec
l'article 44 alinéa 3 de la Constitution
pour en parler j'accueil sur ce plateau
Vincent ayblet bonjour bonjour vous êtes
sénateur socialiste de Seine-et-Marne
vice-président de la commission des
finances un mot sur ce qui s'est passé
ce matin et même depuis hier soir est-ce
qu'il y a changé c'est que le
gouvernement lui aussi maintenant veut
accélérer les débats et utilise des
outils constitutionnels pour rejeter
certains amendements de la gauche oui
c'est tout à fait juste et cela se fait
de façon coordonnée avec la majorité de
droite du Sénat puisqu'en fait
d'un côté lorsque nous imaginons des
amendements ou des sous amendements
destinés à répondre à une priorisation
de l'examen des amendements décidés en
séance on ne réunit pas la commission
des affaires sociales qui pourraient
donner un avis sur ces amendements et
par ailleurs le gouvernement refuse
l'examen des amendements qui n'ont pas
été examinés par la commission et donc
en fait on censure le travail
parlementaire et le travail que pourrait
côté les élus d'opposition dont je fais
partie de façon aller au fond de ce
débat qui concerne nos concitoyens on le
voit chaque jour avec les mouvements
sociaux les manifestations et
l'expression d'une hostilité de
l'opinion française à cette réforme donc
pour contourner cette réalité
aujourd'hui on utilise des artifices de
procédure on ne réunit pas la commission
pour examiner les amendements et mettre
des avis le gouvernement refuse que
puisse être débattue des amendements qui
n'ont pas fait l'objet d'un examen en
commission et donc la boucle est bouclée
et en quelque sorte on va aller vers une
forme de censure encore plus explicite
un 49-3 qui ne dit pas son nom puisque
ici au Sénat il ne porte pas ce nom mais
enfin c'est à peu près la même chose
c'est-à-dire la capacité pour le
gouvernement d'exiger un vote global à
votre bloqué qui ne permettent pas le
travail parlementaire tout ça dans un
cadre qui est celui du choix qui le
gouvernement de l'examen de cette
réforme dans un cadre de textes
budgétaire sécurité sociale qui norme le
temps disponible pour travailler alors
que nous pourrions parfaitement comme
nous le faisons chaque année ancien
président de la commission des finances
en est l'expérience travailler
durablement de nombreux jours sur
plusieurs semaines de façon apaisée pour
aller au fond de l'examen d'un texte
écran très compliqué et qui concerne
éminemment nos concitoyens et qui va
leur coûter deux années de vie alors je
le disais la question 4-3 de la
Constitution aujourd'hui pour bloquer le
vote le débat de cette réforme des
retraites au Sénat et ne sélectionner
que certains amendements Roger carotier
a rappelé que et bien le gouvernement
socialiste au moment du débat sur la
réforme des retraites Touraine en 2013
avait aussi utilisé le vote bloqué à
l'Assemblée nationale en deuxième
lecture de cette réforme à des retraites
finalement est-ce que ce n'est pas de
bonne guerre quand une majorité estime
que l'opposition fait de l'obstruction
oui mais enfin il faut quand même
laisser au débat parlementaire
la possibilité de se développer
aujourd'hui on nous interdit d'examiner
nos amendements en commission et ensuite
en séance on vient nous dire que comme
ils n'ont pas été examinés en commission
on ne peut pas les examiner dans
l'hémicycle non plus donc il y a une
question une forme de censure qui ne dit
pas son nom mais qui est tout à fait
réel que nous ressentons physiquement
voilà moi j'ai moi-même déposé des
amendements qui ne parviennent pas à
franchir le seuil de l'hémicycle de
façon à être débattue et après on vient
nous reprocher que finalement nous ne
sommes pas sur le débat de fond mais que
nous sommes sur un débat de procédure
mais on nous y contraint voilà donc il y
a un jeu de rôle dans cette affaire qui
n'est pas à la gloire du Parlement ici
au Sénat chacun sait où sont les
majorités d'autant qu'on a une
convergence explicite entre les
sénateurs qui soutiennent la majorité
présidentielle et ce de la droite
sénatoriale qui déjà à eux seuls sont
majoritaires donc j'irai globalement on
sait très bien quels sont support de
force mais malgré ces rapports de force
tout à fait caractérisés on vient
malmener l'opposition de gauche du Sénat
de façon à lui interdire en quelque
sorte de prendre la parole sur le fond
en refusant l'examen de nos amendements
qui portent au fond de façon à éviter
sans doute que l'opinion française
puisse constater je dirais l'État les
forces en présence sur ces différents
sujets merci beaucoup Vincent ayblet
pour votre réaction on va retrouver
Quentin calmer dans la tribune de
l'hémicycle Quentin avec une séance qui
ne reprend toujours pas exactement
Alexandre ça ne vous a pas échappé ça
fait 10 minutes que la séance devrait
avoir repris puisqu'elle avait été
suspendue pour 15 minutes mais elle est
sur le point de reprendre c'est imminent
puisque on voit que au plateau ici qui
est l'équivalent du perchoir à
l'Assemblée nationale le plateau au
Sénat on voit que tout le monde se met
en place pour la reprise de la séance le
président la présidente de France qui va
pouvoir rentrer par cette porte et se
réinstaller et que va-t-il se passer à
cette reprise c'est toute la question
va-t-il y avoir le déclenchement de
l'article 44 années à trois de la
Constitution qui viendrait contraindre
un peu plus les débats au Sénat c'est la
rumeur qui brûle depuis maintenant
plusieurs minutes que s'est-il passé
avant cette cette suspension de séance
on a vu une forte tension entre la
droite et la gauche sénatoriale on a
même entendu le vice-président LR du
Sénat sermonner un peu la gauche natale
écoutez Roger carotc on avait bien
démarré
on se met à peu près d'accord sur un
amendement et au moment des explications
de vote 19 sous amendements votre
intention c'est à chaque amendement de
déposer des sous amendements c'est de
l'obstruction presque caricaturale à
partir de là la décision du gouvernement
d'appliquer le 44 2e
et légitime voilà la science qui va
reprendre dans l'instant à l'autre
Alexandre merci beaucoup
Quentin Xavier question simple est-ce
que le gouvernement doit raccourcir ses
débats et utiliser l'article à 43 de la
Constitution pour bloquer le vote du
Sénat sur cette réforme des retraites et
aller et bien directement au vote sur
l'ensemble avec des amendements
sélectionnés par le gouvernement je
voudrais déjà rappeler à ceux qui nous
écoutent que nous sommes à 8 jours huit
jours de débat complet jour et nuit qui
nous ont permis d'aboutir à l'article à
l'article 8 là nous sommes à l'article 8
et donc nous allons article 9 à
l'article 9 pardon
et donc nous avons un certain nombre de
progrès nous avons pu voter nous avons
pu débattre largement sur sur les les
articles les plus importants et donc
nous avions effectivement un certain
nombre d'articles encore à voir sur les
mesures sociales les 6 milliards de
mesures sociales que le gouvernement a
proposé dans son texte initial des
avancées d'ailleurs que le Sénat avec la
commission des affaires sociales ont
proposé également donc on ne peut pas
laisser dire aujourd'hui que le
gouvernement a muselé le Parlement et
que le Parlement n'a pas pu s'exprimer
preuve en est encore une fois nous
sommes au 8ème jour il y a eu des
procédures d'accélération neuvième jour
très exact 9e jour vous voyez j'ai mis
père donc nous avons eu des procédures
d'accélération effectivement nous
permettant à la fois de ne pas avoir de
des amendements d'obstruction des sous
amendements d'obstructions comme nous
avons pu l'avoir depuis 9 jours et de
pouvoir travailler sur le fond sur les
articles de fond et sur les amendements
de fonds qui ont encore une fois parfois
été adoptés à l'unanimité donc on voit
bien que quand on parle de fond on
arrive à trouver un accord au Sénat
après moi je souhaite effectivement
qu'on puisse aboutir parce que nous
sommes des parlementaires et le rôle
d'un parlementaire c'est de pouvoir
voter c'est bien sûr de débattre c'est
d'amander c'est d'améliorer les textes
mais c'est avant tout aussi de voter la
loi et si nous ne votons pas la loi nous
ne servons à rien et donc moi c'est ce
que je dis aujourd'hui au groupe
d'opposition et au groupe de gauche
c'est avant tout de respecter le mandat
qui est qui est le leur c'est à dire de
pouvoir voter les lois personne ne les
oblige à voter pour il y aura il y a des
divergences entre nous et il faut les
assumer mais au moins qu'ils assument le
fait de voter et d'ailleurs c'est ce que
les le mouvement syndical demandent même
la rue la rue ne demande pas de ou le
mouvement syndical ne demande pas de
bloquer il demande de voter contre qu'il
respecte qu'il n'est pas qu'il n'est pas
l'oreille sélective et puis qu'ils
écoutent effectivement ce pourquoi ils
ont été élus c'est à dire voter les lois
je le rappelle ils avaient accovelli
vous êtes sénateurs du groupe RDPI au
Sénat c'est le groupe de la majorité
présidentielle est-ce que vous avez des
informations est-ce que vous savez si le
gouvernement va utiliser cet article 44
alinéa 3 de la Constitution pour bloquer
le vote moi je n'ai pas d'information et
même si j'en avais je vous le donnerai
pas avant que le gouvernement s'exprime
ce n'est pas mon rôle moi je il y a des
outils de la Constitution qui n'ont
jamais été remis en question par les
différents gouvernements successifs donc
la Constitution donne effectivement
confère à la fois des droits au
Parlement et des droits au gouvernement
pour s'assurer que les débats puissent
se dérouler correctement et que nous
puissions avoir des lois qui soient
votées infinies moi je souhaite vous
souhaiterais que le gouvernement utilise
ce vote moi ce que je souhaite c'est que
d'ici dimanche nous puissions avoir une
réforme des retraites qui soit votée
amender préparer et qu'on puisse engager
la commission liste paritaire avec
l'Assemblée nationale à partir du
mercredi matin dans de bonnes conditions
parce que quel signal désastreux si ni
l'Assemblée nationale ni le Sénat ne se
serait prononcé sur sur ce texte donc
oui moi je souhaite que nous puissions
accélérer les débats pour pouvoir voter
ce texte alors la droite sénatoriale et
le gouvernement veulent accélérer les
débats mais quand on regarde un peu où
on en est on est vendredi on est à
l'article 9 il reste mais un peu moins
de 1000 amendements enfin on est en
retard
on n'est pas en retard parce que nous
avons ami un certain nombre de
procédures notamment le 44 2 qui je
rappelle est dénoncé aujourd'hui par le
groupe socialiste mais qui avait été
largement utilisé par le groupe par le
gouvernement socialiste à l'époque pour
la réforme des retraites la réforme
Touraine dans le deuxième lecture à
l'Assemblée nationale rappeler
d'ailleurs par le vice-président karucci
donc on voit bien que c'est un outil
constitutionnel qui est utilisé par les
différents gouvernements pour nous
permettre d'avancer et principalement
sur la question de la réforme des
retraites parce que quand on fait une
réforme des retraites c'est souvent pour
demander un effort supplémentaire aux
Français et donc le débat doit avoir
lieu nous avons eu nous aurons un cas
quasiment 100 heures de de débat au sein
de cette hémicycle je pense que le débat
maintenant doit continuer et nous devons
surtout voter avant dimanche merci
beaucoup à Xavier et d'être venu sur le
plateau Public Sénat direction
l'hémicycle la tribune de l'hémicycle du
Sénat pour retrouver Quentin Quentin
toujours pas de reprise de séance non et
en plus être prise elle crucial et
j’allaise téléspectateurs il faudra
monter le son lorsque la séance va
reprendre car il pourrait y avoir le
déclenchement de l'article 44 alinéa 3
de la Constitution effectivement ce sont
les informations dont dispose Public
Sénat elle a reprises dont on ignore
pour l'heure le moment où elle va avoir
lieu puisque et bien les sources ne
donnent pas plus d'informations pour
l'instant sur l'ordre de la reprise
pourquoi est-ce que c'est crucial est-ce
que ça signifie que et bien en coulisse
sans doute y a-t-il une tractation sur
les amendements ou ou les sous
amendements que le gouvernement pourrait
concerner dans et bien ce qui va se
passer avec le 44 3 le vote bloqué ou le
gouvernement choisi les amendements et
qu'il décide de soumettre au vote au
Sénat on a entendu cette forte tension
depuis une heure dans l'hémicycle entre
la droite naturelle et la gauche
sénatoriale la gauche c'est naturel qui
est bien se plaint d'être bâillonné par
les différents recours à la constitution
au Règlement du Sénat écouter le chef de
fil des écologistes Guillaume Gontard
on avait effectivement bien débuté dans
les quelques minutes de notre de notre
débat ce matin je pensais que la nuit
avait été bonne pour chacun je pense
qu'il faut redescendre ben voilà je
pense qu'il faut peut-être revenir à la
sérénité on a il nous reste à peu près
un peu moins de 1000 amendements
travaillons sur ces oui travaillons sur
ces amendements travaillons sur ses
amendements avançons et tout ira bien
oui Public Sénat donc qui peut et bien
vous dire que à la reprise des travaux
il devrait il pourrait y avoir on va
garder les conditionnel l'utilisation du
44 aliné à trois de la Constitution le
vote bloqué le gouvernement qui peut
choisir ses amendements et les soumettre
au Sénat Alexandre merci beaucoup
Quentin j'accueille sur ce plateau Yann
chanterelle bonjour bonjour vous êtes
sénateur socialiste des Français établir
de France si jamais dans quelques
minutes et bien le gouvernement annonce
l'utilisation de l'article 44 3 de la
Constitution pour et bien un vote bloqué
sur cette réforme des retraites ce
serait un coup dur pour le Parlement bah
oui je suis tout à fait ça serait une
méthode vraiment brutale une sorte de
mini 49-3 au Sénat et bien évidemment
nous nous y opposerons comme nous
l'avons fait depuis le début que des
procédures justement d'accélération de
contraintes ont été mises en place par
la majorité sénatoriale nous nous
laisserons pas faire en tout cas
clairement
là le si vous voulez qu'on évoque ce qui
s'est passé quand même ce matin oui bien
sûr c'est que c'est que en fait tout
simplement ça aurait pu être réglé très
simplement nous ce qu'on reproche c'est
que on dépose des sous amendements ce
qui est le droit d'amendement est sacré
pour les parlementaires c'est l'arme du
pauvre des parlementaires nous avons
déposé des sous-amands pas un grand
nombre c'est à peu près 19
sous-amendement qui ont été à nouveau
via le gouvernement
rejeté nous ce qu'on dit c'est que à
partir du moment où depuis mardi depuis
les manifestations massives le la
majorité sanatoriale souhaite nous
dessus c'est clairement ça elle souhaite
marcher sur les Français aussi qui
manifestent à travers nous puisque nous
nous sommes leur porte-voix ici et donc
nous ne nous laisserons pas faire c'est
ce qu'on essaie c'est ce que je pense à
bien compris la majorité sénatoriale à
chaque fois qu'ils activeront ce taux ce
type de procédé nous ne nous laissons
pas faire nous voulons débattre du fond
nous avons déposé des amendes pas un
grand nombre nous voulons en débattre en
plus c'était pas problématique en fait
le problème principal c'est que la
Commission aurait très bien pu se réunir
pendant 5 10 minutes pour 19 amendements
c'est rapide à juger pour dire ils ne
sont pas recevables n'ont même pas pris
ce temps-là donc en fait il fragilise
même le Parlement à travers leurs
actions vous pensez justement qu'avec
ces manœuvres d'accélération des débats
ici au Sénat de la part de la Commission
de la droite sénatoriale et le
gouvernement ça pourrait fragiliser
constitutionnellement cette réforme des
retraites même si elle était adoptée au
Sénat absolument tous ces artifices qui
sont en train d'être utilisés
fragilisent le texte
déjà on a vu ce qui s'est passé à
l'Assemblée nationale où il a pas pu
l'être au bout si jamais ça ne va pas au
bout qui plus est avec ce genre
d'utilisation d'articles je pense
qu'effectivement le gouvernement
lui-même avec la complicité de la
majorité sénatériale sont à prendre de
prendre un risque en créant des
précédents et en fragilisant le texte
constitutionnellement ou justement
depuis le début ces problématiques c'est
pas faute de le dénoncer on a dit que
c'était problématique d'utiliser
l'article 47 ans dans ce de d'utiliser
le délai contraint pour débattre on a
besoin de temps qu'est-ce qui empêche le
gouvernement de dire très bien nous
avons vu que c'était pas un débat
correct et équitable remettons tout sur
la table reprenons le temps en fait ce
qu'il faudrait faire surtout c'est de se
remettre autour de la table avec l'Inter
cervicale parce qu'il y a quand même
beaucoup de gens pour les écouter pour
essayer d'avoir une une attitude pour
calmer le jeu en quelque sorte
retournons vers les discussions et
reprenons le temps en déposant un texte
qui va permettre de débattre sur la
durée tranquillement comme ça devrait
être fait dans débat parlementaire
finalement il y a une chanterelle est-ce
que vous êtes vraiment surpris par ce
qui est en train de se passer ce matin
on entend vraiment et bien cette
possibilité d'un vote bloqué de la part
du gouvernement d'un côté il y a la
droite sénatoriale et le gouvernement
qui souhaitent un vote finale sur cette
réforme de retraite de l'autre la gauche
rallonge les débats car son objectif
c'est d'empêcher ce vote final c'est une
bonne guerre vous êtes pas surpris non
c'est pas de bonne guerre parce que
comme je l'ai dit tout se passait très
bien jusqu'à mardi soir à partir du
moment où la droite a voulu nous écraser
parce que c'est ça qui s'est passé ce
qui nous ont fait comprendre on dit ce
qui est pas correct ils ont dit on vous
a laissé vous a laissé en de quel droit
on peut dire ça dépend on vous a laissé
débattre jusqu'au le jour des
manifestations et à partir d'aujourd'hui
c'est fini vous vous taisez et c'est
nous qui décidons c'est pas comme ça que
ça fonctionne et ça il faut qu'il
comprenne à chaque fois qu'ils font ça
qui suppriment des sous amendements nous
continuerons à l'asseablement à déposer
pour que les sujets qui ne veulent pas
débattre soit quand même débattus parce
qu'on doit ça aux Français qui se
battent contre cette réforme et qui sont
très majoritairement opposé à la réforme
et si jamais le gouvernement dégaine ce
44 3 ce vote bloqué qu'elle pourrait
être la réponse des sénateurs de gauche
évidemment nous ne laisserons pas faire
nous interviendrons nous ferons bien
évidemment des appels au règlement pour
pouvoir nous expliquer en quel point
justement cette formule est brutale est
fragilise justement le texte plutôt que
le défendre merci beaucoup Yann
chanterelle et on va suivre et bien
l'évolution de ces débats au Sénat sur
la réforme des retraites des débats qui
sont suspendus ce matin depuis quelques
dizaines de minutes on va retrouver
Quentin calmer dans la tribune de
l'hémicycle du Sénat Quentin on va faire
un retour d'abord avec vous sur cette
matinée très tendue dans la Haute
Assemblée oui tout à fait Alexandra on a
vu ce moment où et bien les débats se
sont tendus ont débatté tranquillement
de la retraite des personnes en
invalidité et ensuite et bien Olivier du
stop a déclenché l'article 44.2 qui
permet de faire tomber des sous
amendements écouter le ministre du
Travail
j'apprends à madame la Présidente par
votre intervention que des sous
amendements ont été déposés sur cet
amendement 21 38 je n'ai pas à dire que
si le gouvernement regrette ou pas qu'il
y a des potes sous amendements ça serait
porté une appréciation sur leur contenu
ce n'est pas mon rôle par contre le
gouvernement souhaite en que le Sénat
puisse se prononcer sur des sujets de
fonds et celui-ci en étant en
application de l'article 44 à l'hymne de
la Constitution nous considérons et le
gouvernement considère que tout
amendement ou sous un amendement déposé
sur cette amendement 21 38 et on n'ayant
pas été examinés par la pas été examinée
par la commission sont irrecevables
voilà une procédure déjà utilisée hier
soir en séance c'est ce qui a valu ce
commentaire ironique de Laurence
Rossignol écouter
ça vous a pas suffi hier soir vous avez
aimé ça ou quoi c'est votre vous avez
une petite une petite addiction vidante
votre rappel aux règlements s'il vous
plaît allez-y madame la Présidente
pendant que vous parlez à ma place je
prendrai la suite monsieur le ministre
une addiction on rappellent au règlement
12 amendements là vous déclenchez
ce vote les recevabiliser ça maintenant
pour 12 amendements voilà et de son côté
la droite qui assume et qui soutient ce
recours à la constitution au Règlement
du Sénat pour faire avancer les débats
écouter Roger caoutchi on avait bien
démarré
on se met à peu près d'accord sur un
amendement et au moment des explications
de vote 19 sous amendements votre
intention c'est à chaque amendement de
déposer des sous abonnements c'est de
l'obstruction presque caricaturale à
partir de là la décision du gouvernement
d'appliquer le 44 2e
et légitime et voilà Alexandre pour le
fil de cette matinée cette matinée cette
qui a eu cette suspension de séance elle
devait reprendre à 11h05 la séance elle
n'a toujours pas repris pourquoi que se
passe-t-il on le saura dans quelques
minutes mais d'après les informations
dont dispose Public Sénat et bien le
gouvernement devrait avoir recours dans
les prochaines minutes on continue à
utiliser les conditionnel même si nos
informations sont concordantes devraient
avoir recours à l'article 44 alinéa 3 le
vote bloqué Alexandre merci beaucoup
Quentin justement pour en parler on va
faire réagir Olivier Pacaud bonjour vous
êtes
rattachés au groupe les républicains du
Sénat sénateur de l'Oise est-ce que vous
souhaitez que le gouvernement utilise
aujourd'hui le vote bloqué sur cette
réforme des retraites
j'espère qu'on en arrivera pas là mais
ce que je souhaite c'est que les débats
retrouvent une fluidité qu'ils n'ont pas
il y a une volonté de coagulation pour
prendre un terme sanguin de la part de
nos collègues de gauche sont dans leur
rôle d'opposant mais même s'ils
utilisent des armes qui sont à leur
disposition dans le règlement intérieur
du Sénat on aboutit à une paralysie qui
est quand même navrante
alors
nous souhaitons aller au bout c'est à
dire voter dimanche soir ou avant
Dimanche soir effectivement ce texte un
Parlement n'est pas la seulement pour
parlementer même si c'est dans le mot on
est là aussi pour légiférer c'est à dire
délibérer voter prendre des décisions et
objectivement la volonté de nos
collègues c'est d'empêcher d'aller
jusqu'au bout donc si il faut
effectivement que le gouvernement
utilise cette méthode pourquoi pas ce
serait navrant et je pense que ce serait
un aveu d'échec un peu pour tout le
monde quand même objectivement alors que
le ministre du Travail fait son entrée
dans l'hémicycle du Sénat ça veut dire
que normalement et bien la séance devait
reprendre de manière imminente Olivier
du soft vous dites il y avait un manque
de fluidité dans les débats mais
pourtant ce matin les débats se
passaient plutôt bien il y avait
d'ailleurs un accord entre 7H de gauche
et la terre de droite pour permettre à
ces travailleurs qui sont déc en
incapacité et bien de pouvoir toujours
partir à 60 ans donc finalement rejeter
19 sous amendements de la gauche c'est
ce qu'a fait le gouvernement ce matin
est-ce que justement ça n'a rajoute pas
de l'attention écoutez
l'amendement dont vous parlez du
rapporteur Savary a été voté à
l'unanimité
et cette amendement faisait progresser
le texte justement en prenant en compte
le cas des personnes qui souffrent
d'incapacité à partir de là rajouter 19
sous amendement au dernier moment avec
un unique but gagner du temps jouer la
montre est-ce que c'est responsable non
ce n'est pas responsable je l'ai dit
tout à l'heure dans les débats
malheureusement
nos amis de gauche ont transformé les
travées du Parlement en trancher ils
sont dans une guerre de tranchées de
résistance de perte de temps c'est pas
ça le Parlement c'est pas ça le
Parlement merci beaucoup Olivier Pacaud
pour votre réaction merci je vous laisse
regagner les miss cycles du Sénat en
nous on va retrouver Quentin Calmet en
tribune Quentin ça y est ça va enfin
reprendre la sonnerie qui résonne dans
les couloirs du Palais du Luxembourg la
présidente Nathalie Delattre qui est en
place pour effectivement prononcer la
reprise de la séance les ministres qui
sont au ban la Commission les
représentée donc la séance va pouvoir
reprendre c'est parti retour à la séance
la séance
est parole à Monsieur le
ministre merci madame la présidente
madame la présidente de la commission
des affaires sociales madame et monsieur
le rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
nous débattons du projet de loi de
financement la sécurité sociale
rectificative depuis le 2 mars dernier
dans cette émission vos travaux ont
commencé les jours précédents en
commission de très nombreuses
amendements ont été déposés examinés et
les débats ont été nourris
nous avons eu ensemble dans cette
émission 74 heures de débat sur un sujet
central celui de l'avenir de système de
retraite par répartition
à chaque article malgré des discussions
de fond malgré des avancées portaient
par la commission bien sûr par plusieurs
groupes nous le regrettons mais
l'obstruction est devenue un choix
méthodique et répété des groupes
d'opposition nous avons eu quelques
illustrations pas plus tard que ce matin
je pense à la déclaration de madame la
sénatrice brûle qui nous dit très
clairement et je la remercie de cette
clarté qu'à chaque fois que nous avons
nous avancerons tous sera mis en oeuvre
pour nous ralentir je pense aux
expressions utilisées hier au sujet du
dépôt des sous amendements qui ont été
présentés comme une vie sans fin et avec
la volonté de faire en sorte que le
nombre de sous-amands déposés soit
toujours plus important pour empêcher le
Sénat de se prononcer dans la clarté sur
l'ensemble du texte et sur les
dispositions de fonds je pense aux
séries d'amendements identiques ou
analogue avec des déclinaisons de
professions avec des déclinaisons
d'institutions à concerter avec des
déclinaisons de dattes lorsque les sous
am non comme seul objet que de décaler
d'un jour puis de deux jours puis deux
trois jours puis de quatre jours la date
de remise d'un rapport lui-même demandé
par un parlementaire d'un groupe
d'opposition cela caractérise une
obstruction méthodique et une volonté de
priver le Sénat de sa capacité à
délibérer et à se prononcer dans la
clarté pour dire qui soutient et qui ne
soutient pas les dispositions qui sont
proposées le choix du gouvernement la
ligne du gouvernement la seule qui
vaille à nos yeux et celui de la clarté
des débats pour les sénateurs comme pour
les Français qui nous regardent et qui
vous regardent
nous faisons un choix clair nous avons
une volonté claire celui d'éviter de
contourner et de mettre fin à une
obstruction qui est devenue systématique
et qui n'a comme ça l'objectif je le
répète d'empêcher les sénateurs et les
sénatrices de se prononcer sur les
dispositions de ce texte et sur cette
réforme qui est majeure pour l'avenir
des Français
nous aurions pu considérer que le
calendrier parlementaire tel que prévu
par la Constitution la loi organique
serait suffisant nous considérons qu'il
est absolument essentiel que le Sénat
puisse se prononcer sur le fond dans la
clarté que cette clarté des positions
toute respectueuse dans l'opposition
comme dans la majorité dans le soutien
comme à l'opposition à ce texte mais que
cette clarté des débats est tout à fait
primordiale pour pouvoir ainsi avancer
et que cette réforme puisse continuer à
être discuté
c'est la raison pour laquelle mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs madame la
Présidente en application de l'article
44 alinéa 3 de la Constitution et de
l'article 42 alinéa neuf du Règlement du
Sénat le gouvernement demande à votre
assemblée de se prononcer par un vote
unique sur l'ensemble du texte ainsi que
sur les articles 9 à 20 en retenant les
amendements et les sous amendements
suivants je vous ferai la liste dans un
instant mais en précisant que cette
annonce ne remet pas en cause ce qui a
déjà été examiné et adopté à l'article 9
avant la suspension de semences le
gouvernement propose que soit soumis à
se vote unique les amendements pardon
pour visiterration numéro 21 33 21 34 21
41 21 36 modifié par le sous-amendement
47 61
21 35 21 37 21 39 21 43 21 45 21 44 21
46 21 47 21 48 21 50 et 21 52 à
l'article 9
pour ce qui concerne l'article 10 les
amendements 21 54 20 59 rectifier terre
21 55 20 58 rectifié 20 60 rectifié bis
21 56 21 57 21 58 21 59 et 21 60 pour ce
qui concerne les amendements portant
additionnels après l'article 10 les
amendements 22 95 20 24 20 21 61
rectifié bis 45 47
475 rectifié pour les amendements on
interrompt un instant le ministre parce
que il va égrener une liste
d'amendements pendant les prochaines
minutes mais comme nous vous la lancions
à l'antenne de Public Sénat il y a
quelques minutes le gouvernement en
l'occurrence représenté par Olivier du
socle le ministre travail qui déclenche
l'article 44 alinéa 3 de la Constitution
le vote bloqué et qui est donc en train
de donner tous les amendements qu'il
souhaite voir voter dans la réforme des
puis qu'effectivement cet article de la
Constitution lui permet de choisir la
liste des amendements qu'il souhaite
voir examiner et donc faire tomber tous
les amendements de l'opposition ou
qu'ils ne souhaitent pas voir examiner
et voter par le Sénat c'est donc si on
est en train de se jouer c'est une
nouvelle étape l'étape majeure dans
l'utilisation de la Constitution ou du
Règlement du Sénat puisque c'est une
c'est une arme très contraignante on
retourne écouter le vie du stop
ou encore qui vont nous permettre de
donner suite à un vote intervenu en
première partie permettant la
modification du niveau
du niveau de l'objectif national de
dépenses en matière d'assurance maladie
autant d'amendements qui permettent
d'améliorer ce texte et qui permet de
poursuivre je tiens à préciser mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs que nous
allons pour ce qui concerne les articles
qui suivent notamment les tableaux
financiers avec mes excuses puisque
j'aurais dû traiter l'article 13 dans la
première série de numéros que j'ai
indiqué le gouvernement propose aussi
donc de retenir les articles les
amendements pardonnez-moi
21,66 21 67 21 69 21 70 21 72 21 73
214 21 75 21 76 21 77 ainsi que les
amendements 23 60 rectifié bis 21 78 21
79 21 80 21 82
à l'article 13 que nous proposons aussi
de retenir pour ce qui sera soumis au
vote unique les amendements très 69 et
21 83 qui portent article additionnelle
après l'article 13 l'amendement 252550
25 63 pardon rectifié avant l'article 14
l'amendement 47 23 à l'article 14
l'amendement 47 24 à l'article 15 il
amendement 2184 à l'article 16
évidemment cette liste vaut exclusion de
tous les autres amendements y compris
des amendements portant articles
additionnels
merci Monsieur le Ministre donc en
application de l'article 44 dernier
alinéa de la Constitution et de
l'article 42 alinéa 9 du règlement le
gouvernement demande au Sénat de se
prononcer par un seul vote sur les
articles 9 à 20 et sur l'ensemble du
texte en ne retenant à partir de
maintenant que les amendements proposés
ou acceptés par le gouvernement sans
remettre en cause les amendements
précédemment
adoptés y compris ce adopter jusque à
cet article 9 les amendements restants
en discussion retenus par le
gouvernement viennent d'être listés par
le ministre il reçoit donc en quelque
sorte un avis favorable
si vous me l'autorisez je ne vous
redonnerai pas la liste vous allez avoir
la distribution de cette liste dans
quelques minutes
à l'exclusion donc de tous les autres y
compris des amendements portant articles
additionnels acte est donc donné de
cette demande
mes chers collègues monsieur le ministre
nous avons bien entendu vos propos il
s'agit par le recours à cette procédure
d'assurer la clarté et la sincérité de
nos débats et de mettre un terme à
l'obstruction
mes chers collègues je vous rappelle que
dans le cadre de la procédure de votre
unique les auteurs des amendements
conservent leurs droits de présentation
en conséquence chaque amendement pourra
être soutenu pendant deux minutes et la
Commission et le gouvernement donneront
leur avis il n'y aura en revanche plus
d'explications de vote individuelle sur
chacun des amendements et des articles
je finis de vous expliquer et ensuite
vous ferez des rappels au règlement
laissez-moi finir vous expliquer et nous
ferons ensuite les rappels au règlement
mais certains souhaitent avoir cette
explication
de même les prises de parole sur
articles sont possibles dans les
conditions fixées par la décision de la
Conférence des Présidents réunis le 8
mars dernier c'est à dire à raison de
deux minutes pour un orateur par groupe
à l'issue de la présentation des
amendements nous passerons aux
explications de vote et au vote unique
sur les amendements retenus et sur
l'ensemble du texte
voilà les explications mes chers
collègues je vois quelques rappels au
règlement monsieur Kanner pour rappel au
règlement
merci madame la Présidente sur la base
de l'article 44 bis
la messe est dite mes chers collègues
vous indiquez mes chers collègues que
voilà nous ne sommes pas étonnés
d'ailleurs tout à l'heure dans mon
rappel le règlement je lui ai dit
j'avais dit à Monsieur mimi mais quand
allez-vous sortir le 44 3
c'est fait c'est fait je vous rappelle
que si on en arrive là c'est parce que
bien évidemment des articles du
Règlement général du Sénat ont été
utilisés que le 47 1 de la Constitution
a été utilisée en amont par le
gouvernement et que la tactique et la
technique de l'amendement prioritaire
rectificatif a été utilisé pour faire
tomber nombre d'amendements de
l'opposition
nous donnons acte monsieur le ministre
et Mesdames et Messieurs sénateurs
et sénateur de la droite sénatoriale que
vous avez décidé donc avant la grande
journée du 11 mars
de montrer au pays vous réels intentions
que je qualifierais et ne le voyait pas
mal de réactionnaires puisque c'est bien
une réforme réactionnaire dont nous
parlons aujourd'hui une réforme de
régression sociale il restait 1000
amendement à examiner il nous restait
plus de 30 heures de je crois de débats
et donc nous pourrions nous aurions pu
tranquillement montrer aux Français
notre volonté
nous allons nous allons nous allons
rester je vous assure nous serons en
séance pour débattre des amendements que
vous nous tolérez monsieur le ministre
en termes d'examen mais madame la
Présidente pour nous permettre néanmoins
de prendre acte mais aussi de considérer
les conséquences d'une telle décision du
gouvernement je sollicite de votre part
et je crois que ce sera bien légitime
une suspension de séance pour permettre
aux on a trois groupes de faire le point
de la situation
monsieur le Président je vais d'abord
prendre les autres rappels aux
règlements notamment celui de Monsieur
Gontard pour rappel au règlement
oui merci merci madame la Présidente sur
la partie 44 bis
quel âge de faiblesse quel aveugle
faiblesse ouais
franchement
je crois que franchement je l'ai dit
beaucoup de fois ces derniers temps mais
là un terrible aveux de à votre
faiblesse oui votre majorité se fissure
ce texte n'a pas été voté à l'Assemblée
nationale et on a vu on a vu les
conditions
l'ensemble des syndicats Unis demandent
demande solennellement être reçue par le
Président de la République qui leur
refuse toujours d'ouvrir la porte et de
et de continuer des discussions
l'ensemble de la population et dans la
rue et attend une réponse et vous voulez
passer en force quelle image vous donnez
c'est d'une brutalité c'est une
aliénation du Parlement c'est tout
simplement honteux honteux
Victor Hugo avait appelé son chien
et oui le Sénat est devenu le toutou du
gouvernement voilà où on en est
on en
est alors
la majorité c'est notoriales
effectivement voilà oui allez allez oui
monsieur carucci je sais que ça vous
embête mais je continuerai je continueai
voilà oui rappelle aux règlements oui on
n'a pas le droit de s'adresser quand je
parle voilà ok voilà
donc moi je demande également évidemment
une suspension de séance et les
suspensions de séance qui soient
suffisantes parce que vous vous accordez
une suspension de séance le gouvernement
s'accorde une suspension de séance pour
pouvoir réécrire son texte on a quand
même la possibilité de pouvoir réagir et
pouvoir se réunir mais en tout cas moi
je le dis on ne pourra pas continuer à
accepter cette allégation du du
Parlement et on nous on ne sera pas le
toutou du gouvernement
monsieur le Président Laurent pour
régler rappel au règlement
madame la Présidente nous y sommes voilà
donc le coup de force du gouvernement
que vous prépariez en fait depuis mardi
depuis les appels incessants au recours
à toutes les procédures pour mettre fin
au débat
comme l'a dit à plusieurs reprises la
présidente de notre groupe Eliane
assassy il s'agit effectivement d'un
terrible aveux de faiblesse vous qui
êtes ultra majoritaire au Sénat vous
êtes incapable de faire voter le texte
dans des conditions normales de débat
et tout cela parce que vous avez décidé
parce que vous avez décidé depuis le 1er
jour non seulement de faire voter les 64
ans mais de les faire voter en acceptant
les conditions imposées par le
gouvernement avec le recours aux 47 ans
et vous vous êtes mis dans une situation
d'abaissement du Sénat de jouer le jeu
que vous imposez le gouvernement vous
vous êtes condamné au silence pendant
les premiers jours du débat pour jouer
ce jeu puis à partir de mardi quand vous
avez vu que le mouvement populaire
prenait une telle ampleur vous avez
décidé l'obstruction c'est vous qui avez
organisé l'obstruction depuis mardi pour
finalement justifier ce coup de force du
gouvernement et vous allez donc aller
chers collègues à la CMP mercredi alors
que l'Assemblée nationale n'aura pas
voté le texte et qu'il aura été adopté
ici par en fait ce qu'il faut bien
appeler un 49 sénatoriale parce que le
vote bloqué c'est la même chose donc
vous allez aller à la CMP je vous le dis
mes chers collègues de droite ne
cautionnez pas cela parce que vous le
paierez très cher dans le pays parce que
le pays vous regarde ne cautionnez pas
cela MP la seule issue possible
aujourd'hui
merci madame la Présidente comme vient
de le dire mon collègue Pierre Laurent
le 44 3 c'est le 49.3 du Sénat et
franchement le Sénat ne sort pas grandi
par cette nouvelle procédure le
parlementarisme est piétiné par le
gouvernement je dois le dire mais avec
la sentiment de la majorité de droites
LR
cent triste et c'est triste c'est triste
pour la démocratie c'est triste pour le
peuple c'est triste pour tout celles et
tous ceux qui qui nous regardent et
franchement pourquoi vous avez fait ça
parce que depuis le début procédure sur
procédure vous avez souhaité tendre les
débats vous allez vous avez souhaité
dramatiser les débats et vous avez
refusé de parler du fond c'est à dire
des conséquences de votre projet sur la
vie des gens c'est ça la réalité et
pourquoi il y a une telle attitude des
droites avec le gouvernement c'est parce
que bon le projet du gouvernement c'est
le frère jumeau de votre projet mesdames
et messieurs de droite puisque ça fait
quatre ans ça fait 4 ans que René Paul
Savary présente le recul de l'âge de la
retraite donc vous êtes enfin soulagé de
voir cette réforme scélérate votez de
cette manière-là par des parlementaires
qui acceptent que le parlementarisme
soit piétiné c'est pas glorieux c'est
triste mais les conséquences vont être
graves parce que aujourd'hui vous
piétinez l'opposition et demain
qu'est-ce qui va se passer alors ne
mettez pas la main sur le cœur en disant
oh le Sénat c'est bien mieux que
qu'ailleurs nous nous sommes respectueux
c'est être respectueux que de bafouer
l'opposition de gauche de la baïonnette
bah pour moi c'est anti-démocratique et
c'est ce que vous faites et en plus la
commission des affaires sociales a été
piétiné puisque elle n'a jamais été
réunis depuis le début et ça c'est aussi
très grave
si Madame Rossignol madame la Présidente
Rossignol pour rappel aux règlements
merci madame la Présidente pour que tout
le monde à l'extérieur qui cherche à
comprendre qui s'instruit sur la demande
du Sénat comprennent bien quel est la
conséquence de la décision du
gouvernement en accord avec la majorité
sénatoriale à partir de norean avant
nous n'allons discuter que les
amendements retenus au ballon
gouvernement nous serons tout à l'heure
quand on nous aurons pu examiner la
liste précise combien d'amendements de
l'opposition des groupes de gauche ont
été retenus
je suis pas sûr que tu en es beaucoup
ensuite nous allons discuter des
amendements probablement qui ont convenu
au gouvernement et à la majorité
sanatoriale et quand on dit souvent ses
amendements il y aura je le précise un
orateur pour s'épanou puisqu'on présente
pas l'amendement le rapport la
commission c'est pas nous parce que nous
ne sommes pas importants et ensuite le
gouvernement ce qui revient à dire que
sur tous les amendements que vous avez
retenus qui ne viennent pas de
l'opposition nous ne pourrons pas nous
exprimer c'est ça la procédure que vous
mettez en place alors vous ne pouvez pas
dire que ce n'est pas une procédure
bâillon vous avez décidé que la gauche
devait se taire jusqu'à la fin de ce
débat et puisqu'on parle de la fin de ce
débat puisqu'on parle de la fin de ce
débat il nous devions siéger jusqu'à
dimanche soir vous avez retenu 70
amendements ça peut aller très vite
visiblement votre intention c'est ça
arrive très vite et nous ne sommes que
vendredi midi il y avait encore deux
journées et demi complète de travail
soit 3 6 8 séances 8 séances alors vous
qui voulez faire travailler des Français
deux ans de plus vous n'êtes pas capable
de travailler trois jours de plus c'est
pas glorieux
[Applaudissements]
comme la présidente Rossignol juste de
vous indiquer que tous les amendements
qui restent jusqu'à la fin de la
discussion seront présentés vous aurez
donc à présenter les amendements pas
seulement les amants qui viennent d'être
cités les amendements qui viennent
d'être cités par le ministre ont reçu un
avis favorable mais l'ensemble des
amendements le petit millier qui reste
seront présentés je donne la parole pour
rappel au règlement au président à
Monsieur Hainaut
oui merci madame
la Présidente Monsieur le Ministre
tout au long de ces débats on
s'attendait bien à ce que vous vous
opposiez à ce texte et on en a pas été
surpris on avait vu au compteur un
certain nombre d'amendements mais la
question qui était posée c'était de
savoir si vous vouliez que dans le temps
qui était quand même compter plus de 120
heures de débats nous puissions nous
exprimer et voter et plusieurs fois
Roger caroutchi avec calme et
pondération à appeler les débats à
progresser à avancer
c'est étonnant et se demandant s'il y
avait pas une forme d'obstruction au
fond c'est toute la question bien sûr
qui a ce texte des retraites bien sûr
que vous avez le droit de vous y opposer
nous-mêmes parfois on a des réserves sur
le calendrier sur la forme sur la
question du travail sur le sens du
travail et tout ça c'est le rôle du
Parlement mais le Parlement et c'est
même j'irai dire quelque chose qui
dépasse la réforme des retraites le
Parlement la démocratie représentative
elle doit parler débattre mais aussi
s'exprimer et c'est ça qui fait notre
clivage on n'est pas très heureux de
devoir utiliser une procédure comme
celle là mais pourquoi on fait ça
pourquoi on fait ça
on a parlé de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
quelquefois quelquefois je dis qui rôde
mais c'est pas ça que je vais vous dire
c'est pas ça que je vais vous dire c'est
pas ça que je vais vous dire au moins
lui il y a une différence avec vous
c'est qu'il a l'obstruction glorieuse et
vous vous avez l'obstruction honteuse et
c'est ça mes chers collègues qui depuis
le début est une forme d'hypocrisie vous
ne voulez pas vous exprimer mais vous
vous camouflez derrière des arguments de
procédure et cette obstruction honteuse
elle vous grandit pas et nous on veut
aller au bout de ce de ce texte pour le
Sénat pour la démocratie représentative
je vous remercie
pour rappel au règlement madame pensée
manche pour rappel au règlement
merci madame la Présidente qu'est-ce qui
se joue avec ce 44,3 c'est que le
gouvernement la droite devient
e-libéral il libéral vous devenez
autoritaire et pourquoi bah tout
simplement parce que vous êtes
extrêmement minoritaire et quand on est
minoritaire qu'on veut imposer son point
de vue on devient illibéral vous avez
usé du triptyque bien connu provoquer
réaction répression vous nous avez
provoqué constamment ce matin quel était
le sens de la priorité de l'article
aucun ce que vous vouliez c'est qu'on
fasse des rappels au règlement donc vous
nous avez provoqué nous avons réagi et
maintenant vous nous réprimer en 68
c'était bien connu ça oui tout à fait
moi
personnellement je tiens à adresser un
message au mouvement social qui est
majoritaire et que le gouvernement
malgré cela veut
passer en force oui mais parce que
j'explique rappelle au règlement madame
ponce non je ne peux pas accepter donc
je donne la parole
pour un rappel au règlement en attendant
la Présidente chers collègues donc sur
la base de l'article
sur la base sur la base de l'article 42
9 de notre règlement qui dit comment se
passe les choses quand le gouvernement
dégaine le 44 3 de la Constitution je
crois qu'il faut bien qu'on vienne
conscience les autres que si ça se passe
ainsi ça signifie que nous n'aurons plus
qu'un seul vote un sol sur l'ensemble du
texte et sur l'ensemble des amendements
dont on nous a donné oralement une liste
et dont nous attendons de pouvoir
découvrir ce que nous aurons au menu que
nous aurons à avaler d'un seul coup
d'elle clarté belle sincérité des débats
quand il n'y a que les pour qui
s'exprimeront car ça aussi il faut en
prendre conscience un seul vote mais
systématiquement un seul son de cloche
en trois temps en trois temps je le
concède il y a les auteurs de
l'amendement cela ils sont pour leur
amendement en principe
il y a la commission favorable à ses
amendements et il y a le gouvernement
dont j'ai l'impression qu'il sera
favorable aussi à ses amendements les
autres ce thèse ils écoutent c'est tout
alors je veux bien que que le décorum de
cette émission que notre salle des
conférences que notre palais du
Luxembourg
fasse un petit peu Second Empire c'est
clair mais que notre Sénat bascule dans
sa pratique vers un tel
bonapartiste non non
je vous rappelle mes chers collègues que
les amendements qui ont été élus par le
ministre ce sont ceux qui vont recevoir
un avis favorable mais nous verrons tous
les amendements qui restent dans
l'allias nous verrons donc le petit
millier d'amendements qui nous reste
dans l'allias ceux qui ont été cités par
le ministre sont ceux qui ont un a
priori favorable monsieur Bocquet pour
rappel au règlement
oui merci madame la Présidente
en vertu d'article 49-3 règlements
effectivement je voudrais d'abord donner
lecture de la ligne à 3 de l'article 44
de la Constitution sur lequel on est en
train de se prononcer les uns et les
autres je le cite si le gouvernement le
demande
l'assemblée saisie se prononce par un
seul vote sur tout ou partie du texte en
discussion en ne retenant que les
amendements proposés ou accepter par le
gouvernement en fin de citation
j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire il y a
quelques jours ici que il n'y avait plus
au Sénat qu'un seul bloc libéral pour
soutenir cette réforme libérale il y a
un accord de fond on le sait ça n'est
pas une surprise mais là on est en train
d'assister à une forme de sabordage du
Sénat dans cette république il y avait
le BIC amerisme j'ai envie de parler à
l'imparfait malheureusement le Sénat
joue son rôle dans cette république mais
là on est en train de le saborder et où
est la séparation des pouvoirs dans
cette situation c'est gravissime ce qui
est en train de se passer le ministre
choisit les amendements publics
conviennent sincèrement ce moment est
grave je veux le dire avec solennité
après la crise économique qui sévit
depuis longtemps dans ce pays la crise
sociale qui est en train de s'exprimer
vous allez ajouter une crise politique
majeure dans un pays fracturé et en
tension
madame madame la Présidente se rappelle
à règlement en vertu de l'article 44 bis
de notre règlement intérieur aujourd'hui
vous piétinez le Sénat avec la
complicité de la droite Senatori
gouvernement est responsable de ce qui
se passe depuis le début en ayant choisi
justement l'utilisation du 47 ans qui
limite les débats qui n'ont pas permis
d'ailleurs à l'Assemblée nationale
d'aller au bout des débats et qui
brutalise à nouveau à travers
l'utilisation de cet article de la
Constitution 44-3 pour brutaliser le
Sénat vous avez une pratique du pouvoir
brutal vous prouvez à travers tous ces
artifices l'essoufflement de cette
république de cette cinquième république
aujourd'hui vous en faites à nouveau la
démonstration d'ailleurs
hasard du calendrier sort aujourd'hui un
livre intitulé une république about
souffle que je vous recommande justement
de lire elle montre à quel point les
contradictions les archaïsmes de cette
constitution sa vulnérabilité qui
augmente face aux tentations
autoritaires et qu'un nouveau partage
des pouvoirs serait savateur pour une
république enfin sociale et écologique
mais face ce coup de force que vous
essayez de faire c'est un coup de force
contre les Françaises et les Françaises
qui se battent aussi contre cette
réforme c'est eux que vous brutalisez à
travers ces outils quand vous brutalisez
notre le Parlement c'est pour ça que
malgré tous ces artifices nous serons
nombreux nous appelons justement les
Françaises et les Françaises de se
mobiliser en masse encore plus nombreux
et nombreuses face à cette volonté de
nous brutaliser car samedi nous serons
avec eux dans la rue
désormais les Français
à partir du moment où leur privé de
débats
monsieur kerouge vous demande de faire
votre appel au règlement en indiquant
l'article auquel vous faites référence
[Musique]
c'est Monsieur keroski là-bas à la
parole pour son rappel au règlement
monsieur kerouche sur quel fondement du
rappel au règlement
madame la Présidente
encore une remarque à notre collègue
Hainaut parce qu'il nous interpelle vous
êtes obstiné monsieur par Jean-Luc
Mélenchon vous faites une fixation il y
a de très bonnes consultations
psychologiques en ce qui nous concerne
en ce qui nous concerne nous sommes
socialistes écologistes et communiste
bien
un bel exercice quand même commun de
médiocrité parlementaire parce que
vous nous expliquez l'ensemble des
mesures ou des dispositions que nous
aurions prises pour ne pas faire avancer
le débat ou pour faire obstruction ceci
étant je rappelle notamment pour le
Conseil constitutionnel que par exemple
il y a une collusion évidente entre la
commission des affaires sociales et sa
présidente et le gouvernement parce que
en ne réussissait en ne réunissant pas
la commission cela permettait de mettre
en place l'article 44 alinéa 2 c'est de
la collusion ensuite vous avez utilisé
l'article 38 avec une seule prise de
parole l'article 42 10 le temps
déterminé l'article 44-6 sur les
priorités l'article 46 bises 2 sur les
examens disjoints l'article 46 bis 4
dites-moi vraiment qui a fait de
l'obstruction parlementaire qui
en fait
en fait nous aurons eu avec ce débat la
preuve que cette réforme était mauvaise
je salue la présence de franquiester qui
le premier a manifester le fait que
cette réforme se faisait au détriment
des femmes et bien tout le long de
l'examen tout le long de l'examen nous
aurons montré que cette réforme est très
mauvaise et je terminerai par une
formule bien connue mais elle est
vraiment vérifiée aujourd'hui la
roche-tard Payenne n'est pas loin du
capital du Capitole pardon
je voyais monsieur
car je
voyais très sérieusement le succès que
vous pensez avoir aujourd'hui et déjà la
défaite de demain
madame
merci madame la Présidente je crois que
le temps du débat c'est le gouvernement
qui la volontairement réduit d'abord en
soumettant l'examen de ce texte à
l'article 47 1 qui oblige à finir ce
débat dimanche minuit et qui ensuite
refusent d'ouvrir ce qui reste possible
le débat au-delà de dimanche minuit il
serait d'ailleurs peut-être encore temps
de le faire parce qu'il reste un certain
nombre d'amendements à exposer et je
pense que si vous vouliez vraiment
montrer que vous êtes prêt au débat vous
ouvrirez la séance au-delà de dimanche
la majorité sénatoriale ne s'est en
effet pas grandi de prêter le flanc à
toutes ces manœuvres elle s'est réduite
à une béquille du gouvernement en se
prenant les pieds dans le tapis puisque
toutes les procédures activées depuis
plusieurs jours maintenant non contribué
qu'à une seule chose c'est à retard er
encore le débat et à ne pas avancer sur
l'examen du texte
je crois que ce vote bloqué vous
l'activez aussi parce que dans la
majorité sénatoriale comme dans la
majorité présidentielle les fractures et
les lézards se font de plus en plus
ouvertes ici je l'ai eu l'occasion de le
dire et je vais le redire
55 de nos collègues qui appartiennent au
banc de la droite et du centre ont
refusé de voter l'article 7 c'est ça qui
vous pose problème je tiens c'est
absolument leur droit et nous les en
félicitons ce qui est en revanche
irresponsable c'est que à activer ce
petit frère du 49-3 vous allez redoubler
la colère du pays et c'est absolument
irresponsable dans le contexte où nous
sommes pour ce qui nous concerne nous
allons continuer de défendre argument
après argument les méfaits de cette
réforme qui repousse l'âge de la
retraite de deux ans vous pouvez compter
sur nous nous ne lâcherons pas sur
chacun de nos arguments
monsieur gay
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues j'avais vu
que le président rotaïo c'était
inscrivant moi j'espère que je lui passe
pas devant
vous avez perdu le débat politique
l'utilisation du 49-3 sénatorial c'est
la preuve que vous avez perdu le débat
politique vous avez d'abord accepté le
47 heures la procédure contrainte pour
les débats y compris vous avez un texte
qui a pas été voté à l'Assemblée
nationale puis ici après l'obstruction
silencieuse vous avez utilisé
l'obstruction réglementaire en allant
chercher ce bouquin au fin fond d'une
armoire poussiéreuse avec des arguments
et des règlements qui n'avaient jamais
utilisé été utilisé auparavant et je
vous le redis vous ne règlerez pas la
question politique par des argusies
réglementaires et maintenant vous vous
en remettez au gouvernement qui active
l'arme du 49-3 sénatorial pour mettre
fin
à nos débats mais le débat il continue à
l'extérieur des millions de travailleurs
et travailleuses se sont mis puissamment
en grève et celles et ceux qui nous
regardent qu'ils sachent une chose nous
continuerons à défendre nos arguments et
nos amendements jusqu'au bout vous allez
être contraintes d'entendre tout ce que
nous voulions débattre et il faut
continuer à se mobiliser puissamment
samedi parce que nous voulons une chose
et nous ne céderons rien et les trois
groupes de gauche écologistes
socialistes et communiste resteront uni
et rassemblée jusqu'au retrait de cette
réforme unique et chers collègues vous
êtes rentrés très fort et majoritaire
vous en sortez affaibli et tout petit et
si vous pensez que vous allez régler la
chose à 14 dans une salle en CMP contre
la majoritaire des Français vous vous
courrez merci
ça va le délit pour rappel au règlement
monsieur symbole d'Élie pour rappel au
règlement
oui merci 44 bises vous avez raison
d'être vigilante
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues d'abord je trouve que
franchement
j'écoutais madame borne qui nous
rappelait mercredi
elle a évoqué la séparation des pouvoirs
je suis assez scandalisé de la
proposition du missile du socle en
l'absence du président du Sénat
c'est un événement important pour notre
institution donc on choisit pas
on minimum on se respecte et je peux
d'autant plus me dire que vous le savez
mes collègues Galler j'ai porte une
appréciation assez dure à l'encontre de
notre président à un moment donné de nos
débats avec vous me connaissez avec ma
sincérité s'agissant l'obstruction
monsieur Hainaut alors là franchement
ne portons pas des mots plus haut qu'on
n'a pas besoin d'invective ici personne
n'a à avoir honte moi je vais vous dire
des 145 LR des 145 élèves il y a la 127
qu'on vote pour mais les autres n'ont
qu'une honte à avoir les centristes
étaient 50 157 INAC 35 ont voté pour
mais les autres n'ont pas de honte à
avoir les indépendants Républic et
territoires sont 24 22 ont voté pour les
deux autres n'ont pas de honte à avoir
et je peux continuer la liste comme ça
donc il n'y a pas eu d'obstruction il
n'y a pas eu d'obstruction il y a des
parlementaires des sénatrices et des
sénateurs qui ont eu l'occasion
d'exprimer des votes contraires donc il
n'y a pas eu obstruction du débat vous
n'avez pas changer compris des éléments
de votre majorité c'est pas sérieux et
puis après là quand même on est dans un
duo là franchement c'est impressionnant
on a un article 7 qui est réécrit en duo
en 10 minutes après on nous a fait
l'article 38 moi je vais vous dire ce
qui est en train de se passer vous êtes
en train de créer un régime des pleins
pouvoirs voilà ce que vous êtes en train
de faire et vous et je le dis à la
majorité c'est lauriade sénatoriale en
acceptant le diktak du gouvernement vous
êtes en train de faire de la béquille
parce que vous êtes en train de préparer
un nouveau régime parce qu'on est en
train d'affaiblir les deux assemblées le
pouvoir parlementaire et je vous dis ça
sans invective et sans polémique il y a
82 % de Français en colère ce matin
82% de français en colère ce matin
Madame Van
[Applaudissements]
eye en vertu de l'article 44 bis
personne n'est dupe monsieur le ministre
chers collègues de la majorité
sénatoriale
votre pénible liste à la Prévert de
justification à votre décision de
piétiner l'opposition n'a rien à voir
avec la réalité de ce qui s'est passé
ici et avec la brutalité qui s'est
exprimée c'est vous monsieur le ministre
Mesdames et Messieurs les collègues de
la majorité sénatoriale qui nous avait
muselé bâillonner
Bayonnais embarrassé
embarrassé que vous êtes
par nos arguments et nos propositions en
opposition à votre réforme réactionnaire
et néfaste pour les Français
les Français n'y comprennent plus rien
mais il doit savoir que c'est un coup
d'État que vous venez de déclencher ici
au Sénat
et vous allez tristement aujourd'hui
marqué l'histoire
je m'y ai pour rappel au règlement
merci Madame la prudente au moins trois
articles 46 bits 44 bits 44 terre
je
à cet instant je constate que la
discussion a démarré avec un accord
politique légitime oui oui monsieur
carochi légitime entre la majorité
sénatoriale et le gouvernement sur le
fond d'un texte
vous nous avez donné l'habitude d'être
plus placide chers privé
et cet accord politique s'est transformé
et c'est là quel problème en accord
institutionnel
la constitution de notre République elle
donne beaucoup de pouvoir à l'exécutif
plus que dans tout autre démocratie
parlementaire et le règlement du Sénat
il tente de préserver les droits de
l'institution parlementaire
l'activation du 49-3 fait partie des
prérogatives constitutionnelles du
gouvernement 44-3 pardon constitutionnel
du gouvernement le ministre choisit de
l'activer
mais là nous avons assisté à autre chose
nous avons un système majorité
sénatoriale qui a organisé l'activation
de cet article avec le gouvernement
il en résulte une confusion
institutionnelle qui est grave vous ne
défendez plus le Sénat vous utilisez les
outils que notre Constitution donne à
l'exécutif pour activer accélérer
l'adoption d'un texte au Sénat vous
n'utilisez pas le fait majoritaire là
vous utilisez vous vous pliez à une
demande de gouvernement avec les outils
de l'exécutif et ça c'est grave et ça
c'est grave parce que je comprends que
le fait majoritaire vous donne le droit
de faire voter un texte vous pouvez vous
exclamer comme nos droits d'opposants
nous donnent le droit d'accéder les
outils pour le freiner mais là vous avez
franchi le Rubicon vous êtes mis dans la
main de l'exécutif
voyez pour rappel au règlement
merci Madame madame la Présidente au nom
de l'article 42 9 et à propos de
l'article 44 3 de la Constitution
nous parlions au début de ces débats de
des traditionnels débats feutrés du
Sénat et nous allons terminer sur des
débats Bayonnais la démocratie se mesure
au respect des minorités mais aussi des
syndicats des corps sociaux pour les
syndicats lorsqu'ils demandent à être
reçus par le Président de la République
la première ministre les renvoie dans le
bureau de Monsieur du soft
du respect je ne le sais pas sans
vouloir manquer de respect au ministre
je pense que l'ampleur de la
manifestation nécessitait que le
président l'ai reçu en ce qui nous
concerne après le choix d'un véhicule
législatif qui contraint nos débats et
qui nous oblige à terminer dans les
délais contraints fixés par l'article
47.1 pour voter vite trop vite cette
mauvaise réforme avec votre accord et
l'âge chers collègues de la majorité
sénatoriale voilà donc le 44 3 utilisé
pour bâillonner c'est le mot
l'opposition sénatoriale et hélas je le
dis avec la complicité de la majorité
sénatoriale je suis tout récent ici j'ai
toujours vu les sénateurs bataillés pour
le respect de leurs droits et de la
capacité d'agir et de débattre du
Parlement
et si cette capacité est mise à mal
après que reste-t-il que reste-t-il
chers collègues lorsque les
manifestations sont méprisées monsieur
le ministre que reste-t-il quel article
de la Constitution permet de bâillonner
des millions de manifestants et vers
quel régime allons-nous aller
pour rappel au règlement pardon monsieur
Dantec
oui merci madame la présidente rappelle
au règlement évidemment sur la base du
44 bisous je voudrais vous relire
l'article 28 le Premier ministre après
consultation du président de l'assemblée
concernée ou la majorité des membres de
chaque assemblée peut décider la tenue
de jour supplémentaire de séance avec le
47 ans nous avons 50 jours nous pouvons
donc aller plus tard que dimanche si
vous vouliez vraiment que nous débâtions
vous aviez la possibilité par la
constitution de rajouter des jours et
c'est ce que j'ai d'ailleurs proposé
hier soir simplement vous ne le voulez
pas et ce matin vous avez même multiplié
les
provocations y compris pour se faire
tomber 10 sous amendements pour
justement arriver à ce que vous aviez
décidé depuis déjà longtemps je crois
qu'effectivement ça a été dit par mes
collègues c'est un affaiblissement
terrible du Parlement c'est un
affaiblissement du Sénat avec le soutien
de la majorité sénatorial et je vais pas
être très très long
ça parlera aux quelques gaullistes qui
sont encore sur les bandes droites je
crois que le titre de ce qui se passe ce
matin c'est balle tragique au Sénat un
mort la société française qui sort plus
fragilisée que jamais
monsieur Paco pour rappel aux règlements
oui madame la Présidente merci en vertu
de l'article
alors on a entendu des mots quand même
assez fort le président Kanner a parlé
de réactionnaire
notre ami salvaudelli a parlé des pleins
pouvoirs les pleins pouvoirs ils ont été
votés à Pétain en juillet 40 c'est quand
même une référence navrante on a parlé
de bonapartisme ce n'est pas le 18
brumaire le ministre du socle n'est pas
Joachim Murat il n'y a pas de grenadier
pour vous sortir d'ici
vous avez parlé
il n'y a qu'un seul regret c'est que
nous soyons contraints de subir ce que
vous appelez un 49-3 sénatorial nous
aurions tous aimé vous comme nous mais
peut-être pas avec la même sincérité
aller jusqu'au bout du vrai débat cette
espèce de 49-3 sénatorial il est
provoqué il est provoqué il faut que
vous l'assumiez par votre coagulation
des débats votre attitude aboutissait à
une embolie sénatoriale et je suis navré
de conclure en utilisant la morale du
rat et de l'huître de la Fontaine tel
est pris qui croyait prendre
monsieur pour rappel au règlement
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur les
ministres mais mes chers collègues les
Français et les Françaises nous
regardent et ne comprennent qu'une seule
chose face à cette émission les
républicains du Sénat sont entrés au
gouvernement voilà ce que les Français
comprennent aujourd'hui nous sommes face
à une crise politique majeure majeur
l'autorité du Président de la République
est en question l'autorité de la
première ministre étant question le
groupe majoritaire de l'Assemblée
nationale a éclaté il ne reste plus
qu'au gouvernement l'assurance de
pouvoir disposer des votes du groupe
républicain au Sénat chers collègues je
vous pose la question est-ce que vous
allez sauver le quinquennat d'Emmanuel
Macron
monsieur dossier pour rappel au
règlement sous quel fondement monsieur
dessus
au 44 bis madame la Présidente merci on
va remettre un peu de contexte parce que
j'entends un peu n'importe quoi qui est
racontée sur les rangs de la droite
qui réécrit qui réécrit largement
l'histoire de ce débat qui réécrit
largement l'histoire de ce débat on a eu
un débat serein jusqu'à mardi à peu près
on a étudié jusqu'à 6 articles
sereinement ça a été long évidemment
mais on a étudié six articles
sereinement jusqu'à mardi mardi il s'est
passé quelque chose les Françaises sont
levés ils sont ils vous ont dit à quel
point ils rejetaient cette réforme les
grèves ont commencé à se mettre en place
et là ça a été le début de la panique
début de la panique c'est 1000
amendements de la gauche qui sont tombés
pour un effet de procédure ensuite ça a
été la montée en puissance du règlement
42 38 44 de hier mais aussi les débuts
de la fissure on a vu certains de des
sénateurs de droite et du centre qui ne
votaient pas l'article 7
on a vu aussi qu'à l'Assemblée nationale
les menaces commençaient à pleuvoir sur
les les députés de la majorité qui ne
voteraient pas ce texte aujourd'hui pour
12 sous amendements 12 sous amendements
c'est une demi-heure de débats 12 sous
amendements le ministre a craqué il a
sorti le 44-3
il nous reste 900 amendement 900
amendements
où il y a les 1000
1000 sous amendements il nous restait
trois jours de débat on aurait même plus
ouvrir une journée de plus on aurait pu
aller au bout c'était les débats sur le
sucré de la réforme sur les mesures
d'atténuation de la brutalité de la
réforme mon avis hier quand on a
commencé à les débattre qu'on avait même
plus à les expliquer ici que personne ne
comprenait que c'est que ces mesures
d'atténuation n'étaient pas à la hauteur
donc on vient comprendre ce qui se passe
c'est à dire que vous n'arrivez pas à
masquer la brutalité de la réforme vous
arriverez plus à l'assumer ces débats et
donc vous essayez de nous faire taire
tout le monde l'a compris mais vous n'y
arriverez pas et demain les stations
seront massives monsieur Tissot pour
rappel au règlement
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues mon rappel
au règlement sera sur la base de
l'article 42 alinéa neuf de notre
règlement alors que l'avenir des
Françaises et les Français est en jeu et
que nous débattuons du droit à avoir une
retraite en bonne santé et un repos
mérité après de longues carrière
érintantes je suis profondément choqué
par le contournement du Parlement et du
débat démocratique décidé par le
gouvernement en seulement 30 minutes
chers collègues de la majorité
sénatorial en acceptant la proposition
du gouvernement prenez-vous conscience
de ce que vous venez d'accepter alors
que vous cessez vous ne cessez de
rappeler la grandeur du Sénat à laquelle
je crois vous venez de réduire au néant
son rôle institutionnel au sein de notre
République
je souhaitais revenir sur les propos de
notre collègue qui parlaient
d'obstruction honteuse des groupes de
gauche et vous mon cher collègue
n'avez-vous pas honte de refuser un
débat sur un texte qui privera les
Français de deux ans de vie et de
projets à accomplir
moi j'aime bien quand la droite
manifeste quand je parle parce que ça
veut dire que moi en tant qu'élut de
gauche je touche juste
monsieur du soft monsieur le ministre
vous justifiez cette manœuvre de
contournement vous faire aboutir un
texte de loi
soi-disant de justice sociale pourtant
mardi dernier plus de 6000 personnes
étaient réunies dans une ville que vous
connaissez bien Annonay commune vous
avez été maire député de cette
circonscription commune qui joue
justement des partement de nombreux
manifestements rappelaient qu'il y a 12
ans vous manifestiez alors côté contre
la réforme des retraites des rivort en
dénonçant et se sont vos mots de
l'époque une réforme doublement injuste
pensez-vous cette fois que votre réformé
juste monsieur le ministre je pense que
l'ensemble des interventions que nous
avons plus sur le rappel aux règlements
monsieur demande la parole
merci
merci madame la Présidente la madame la
Présidente je souhaitais finalement
réagir à quelques-uns des rappels au
règlement sur un point en particulier
mais monsieur Tissot évoquant une
commune qui m'est cher m'invite
finalement à réagir plus vite encore
qu'est-ce que je le pensais je dis ça
vous avez évoqué la manifestation qui
s'est déroulée dans ma commune celle où
j'habite et ça me permet d'apporter un
élément nouveau et je le dis en
précisant que aucun destinateur ici
présent n'est responsable de cela
j'ai indiqué il y a quelques heures de
débat maintenant peut-être deux jours
que de 10h à 15h 2400 foyers de ma
commune avait été privé d'électricité
après une coupure volontaire
cette coupure volontaire a entraîné la
nécessité pour les lycées de fermer
leurs portes empêcher les commerçants de
travailler à nécessité que les pompiers
interviennent pour débloquer délivrer
plus exactement des personnes bloquées
dans des ascenseurs à contraint les
résidents d'un foyer de personnes âgées
à manger froid et des interventions de
pompiers pour des personnes placées sous
respirateur et à causé le désordre que
vous imaginez cette coupure volontaire
monsieur le sénateur a été depuis
revendiqué par la CGT énergie
si c'est de ce mouvement social dont
vous réclamez je ne suis pas sûr que ça
participe à la clarté ou à la légitimité
des débats
ensuite
j'ai entendu à plusieurs reprises des
mots qui je crois dépassent largement le
cadre de nos débats
j'ai entendu et les rappels du cas des
rappels le règlement mais monsieur le
Président roching n'étant pas moi-même
sénateur je n'ose me prononcer sur cet
aspect là sur les mots que j'ai entendus
coup de force
bâillon censure régime il libéral il
démocratique coup d'État régime
autoritaire je crois véritablement que
ça n'est pas nécessairement adéquate
lorsqu'on met en oeuvre une procédure
prévue par la Constitution par notre
texte principal par des dispositions qui
autorisent le gouvernement à solliciter
du Parlement une seule chose c'est la
clarté d'impositionnement et d'un débat
j'ai aussi entendu des discours ou des
interventions offusqués disant mais
finalement que faites-vous personne n'a
jamais osé faire cela c'est absolument
incroyable les quelques rappels qui se
sont succédés m'ont permis de consulter
les archives du Sénat
le 20 avril 2013 après 18h de débats
après l'examen de 156 amendements sur
les 679 qui étaient déposés sur le
projet de loi relatif à la sécurisation
professionnelle
qui comptait 20 article c'est le hasard
de la comparaison un de mes
prédécesseurs Michel Sapin
avait recours à l'article 44 2
considérant qu'il n'y avait pas